foreign
we are off the rails and it is January
18th
beautiful uh sunny day here over in Los
Angeles coming at 55 degrees high is 60.
coming at you take care on those
freeways keep your eyes on the road
people 800.
DPI I forgot about this guy
[Music]
all different flavors flavors flavors
flavors flavors flavors we
think we are to do is we are Muslims
Muslim we are religious we are secular
we are gay my penis was oscillating to
its half a sensitive from a touch of
toucher flavors culture flavors culture
flavors flavor flavors
oh do you have a choice
flavors
[Music]
wow
you all watching have a choice
red or blue mother effers today's
episode is sponsored by honey and stamps
obviously by watching the show you've
chosen by default to take the red pill
um I will oh here's an update on the
Elon Musk shirts because lots of people
were asking about that
they're arriving at a fulfillment center
the end of January
and they'll be shipping out the first
week of February
so just it'll keep you guys updated
um it's it's close
you know the last end of the last
episode
it's too hot and that's my fault
I asked them to turn up the heat a
little bit for Shredder
uh but it's really hot
thank you Shredder's here with me I
ended the last episode yesterday of
course uh talking about
Shredder who's unfortunately Fallen uh
or has been ill I guess for a long time
with both acute and chronic kidney
disease
he was in the hospital for three days
he's back with us right now he's sitting
next to me resting
this morning we gave him an IV
and he's got on all kinds of Medicine
including antibiotics which I guess they
think he might
have an infection in his kidney but I
don't know
he's on two different antibiotics
and uh
I don't want to be down he's in a really
high spirits today you know it's just
been an emotional roller coaster for me
because
one vet says he's going to die the other
one says he's going to live
last night he wasn't eating
and I was like just crying and messed up
all night because I thought he was gonna
die and this morning he had a little bit
and he's in pretty good spirits
he ran right up to me and gave me a look
on the nose so yeah he was all excited
so that's good yeah seemed energetic no
he was he was in a really good mood this
morning he got his IV he ate a tiny bit
but I swear to God this dog is going to
be he doesn't he's the pickiest eater I
can't tell you guys so I don't know how
the F he's not allowed to eat like
protein chicken beef anything which was
like
and
um
I don't know how I'm gonna get him to
eat that's like my biggest concern right
now
and there's just so many conflicting
opinions and reports we are getting
second and third opinions
from that
so we're gonna get you know the best
medical advice and treatment we can but
today he seems to be having a good day
and he ate a little bit this morning so
I was feeling pretty good
but it's crazy it's just been an
emotional roller coaster but he's here
with me
he's home good yeah good good it's been
really nice but I can't tell now now I'm
like super
like I'm I think maybe I'm over
analyzing all of his behavior now
um it's hard not to like I was in a
great mood he came in and then when he
came up the stairs super slow and then
he's walking in the office super slow
and then that bummed me out like right
when we arrived I don't know if you
noticed that right after that he jumped
on me though okay which was good because
downstairs he was he was like loving it
he was jabbing and then he starts
walking like so [ __ ] slow yeah
probably needed a second sometimes I
need a second yeah the stairs after the
stairs the stairs I got to start
carrying them up those stairs yeah
probably because usually he'd hit those
hard with no problem you know right
after that he crushed those things
pumpkins people say yeah you guys say he
will not eat pumpkin do you guys
understand like how absurd even the idea
is pumpkin chicken broth I could
probably he might like that
like I wonder can you guys help me do
some because
I keep seeing he can eat honey or syrup
that might be good he might actually
like that over five star diet it tastes
like beef jerky I'm star diet that's
funny
no I did man are you doing a tribute are
you doing this
um but then I we had a tech over our
house helping us give him my IV this
morning and he said don't do that
someone yeah I carrying food sounds
possibly good
um
all dogs love pumpkin trust me dude he
will [ __ ] laugh at your face if you
try to give him no sodium chicken broth
okay that's actually a good idea
um bone broth
yeah
so I don't know man it's baby food I
heard that a lot you could that
apparently dogs love baby food I did see
someone on the sub said that their dog
was diagnosed with kidney failure and
they heated up their dog's food in the
microwave and that was the only way that
yeah I do that so I'm on every level I
am seeing people saying that you could
use syrup syrup okay yeah
syrup and then I was thinking well the
protein's the problem what about fat
because he loves like chicken fat like
can I just get his food kind of greasy
because he'd eat it then I feel like
then I asked the tech today he said no
don't do that or no Lena called the
doctor says I don't know man
green beans y'all really tripping balls
if you think he's going to eat a green
bean
if I could give him boiled chicken he'd
eat that
but anyway whatever I could discuss this
all day we actually have a shout at you
we did our members live stream yesterday
and uh appreciate everyone there it was
basically this too I was just
troubleshooting
oh God it's it's it's stressful man
plain Greek yogurt he would eat that but
I don't know
with a smidge of honey
I can because that's what I eat I was
gonna say that sounds pretty good you
serious he can eat that he would go
crazy for that
I left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt that I wanted yeah because
doesn't yogurt have a ton of protein in
it I mean that's the problem uh yeah it
does yeah it does have protein in it
maybe not a ton but if he's supposed to
not have any protein then well I I have
a choice like I have to he has to eat so
I'm trying to figure out like what's the
lowest protein food I can mix in that's
going to get him interested in his food
it says I'm seeing plain yogurt with
honey
he can eat that that's what I'm seeing
on this website yeah he can eat that
like his like
like how much of that can he eat again
though that has protein in it I wouldn't
right no but he's got to have protein
right he still has to eat protein can't
be like animals got to be super low
protein it says usually low protein is
suggested but just as important as the
quality and digestibility of the protein
Source ooh so can you write to um
about to ask about yogurt and honey yeah
[ __ ] yeah
ground turkey
all right y'all are full of um
y'all are full of suggestions but okay
we're still doing 99 lean turkey oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay you know
what's funny I I'm gonna be honest with
you guys he doesn't like turkey
based he won't eat turkey he doesn't
like it I swear to God you and me both
shredder like I'm telling you you don't
understand how picky this dog is and
it's [ __ ] driving it's gonna I mean I
don't know what to do
it's kind of cute only listen to the vet
I dude these vets are a nightmare you
guys don't understand
where I'm trying to get advice from them
but we're going to see a new vet
on Tuesday
who's coming to our house and then
there's another vet that a friend
recommended uh that we're gonna go get a
third opinion
from
kabish liver
that can't be good for him can it
shout outs probably said every dish uh
and yeah people are literally saying
everything right my brain is saying him
eating liver equals good it does does
that make sense but I don't I don't know
I don't think it works that way because
like he can't he's got to have low
protein no salt and no phosphorus I
don't know what the [ __ ] phosphorus is
does anyone know what the [ __ ]
phosphorus is well it's a chemical
element and uh
the white variant of phosphorus is not
something you want to be around comes
yeah liver should be avoided yeah
liver's got to have like all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] in it cheeseburgers carne
asada tacos yeah there you go there you
go he would love that he would sure love
that I'm seeing lebanes okay
let's get on that Nina and ab diet
just give them kidneys oh that's an
interesting idea
right
there's a logic in that I I see what I'm
saying I say don't even look into it
just just give him dots I'm lacking on
the kidney let's give them I'm gonna
Harvest dog kidneys
and I'm gonna feed it to him Raw
people are literally saying brat first
y'all are crazy yeah you guys are
literally just [ __ ] how about Taco
Bell okay
I pull up to talk about yo can I get
your no sodium no phosphorus uh can we
get some uh Nacho Bell Grande please
Kebab Pizza
uh that'd be good yeah I saw somebody
say chocolate cake does that work
chocolate cake definitely that's a good
idea without phosphorus yeah yeah true
you consider to give him some [ __ ]
weed man weed okay here's everything
kidney beans cheese
thank you uh fousey
yeah this you guys aren't helping me at
all
yeah that did wonders for me yeah that's
gonna kill him on the spot Cam's tour to
Arby's yeah that'll be good thank you
FICA fish okay thank you guys thank you
thank you that's too far we've gone off
the off the side of the of the building
thank you
oh brother yeah this sucks it just sucks
it sucks [ __ ]
suck not wrong and I don't know how long
he has I don't even know how healthy he
is right now I don't know anything and
it's like just the not knowing makes me
all the time
I'm thinking about it all the time and
I'm just so anxious and I'm like
watching all these behaviors
I don't know how to live like this
honestly
I don't know how to live like this
because like I can't like live normally
because every it's just I'm so I don't
know what's going on
I guess you guys will have to adapt to a
more difficult normal for sure
all right
anyway thank you for being here
everybody
yes yes we made okay moving on he's here
he's next to me God bless
we made a H3 bingo card
we are going to be
you can play along at home can they play
along at home
we gotta sell Bingo cards like David
dobrik and then maybe one of them you
get like a DOT you have like a one you
have a point zero zero zero zero zero
zero one percent chance of winning a
million dollars something
uh H3 bingo
do we all have the same options just
scrambled up
check all these out
love moves to the USA
very likely Abe wins his creator Clash
fight I see that happening
significant evidence of alien life is
discovered okay is this the year let's
find out this is the year
Drake faces a major cancellation
that's a wild card cause my top five is
drake drake drake drake drake drake
Ethan and Hassan kiss now that that
actually could be a conflict of interest
because I directly affect that one
but it's on my card so well that's true
for a lot of these these were all uh
there's three permaband that's
completely in your hands as well pull
out these were all our predictions and
uh suggestions maybe I'll get permaband
just to finish my bingo people at the
live show
see now I can hear him breathing Ethan
gets below 200 pounds and Dan has to put
mayo on his Dome that's that's within
your hands as well
I can hear him breathing he's breathing
loud
who
Shredder oh
well
love
well
but not but he looks fine
see this is better than my breathing
than not okay
love the optimism that's good
It's My Life
the podcast tries to drastically
different format and it works where's
the one where we tried different formats
it fails immediately and we do one
episode of it and never talk about it
Joe Biden afterlife
very soon Joe Biden
Tesla completely tanks I mean that's
kind of already happening
Ethan makes another bomb threat I mean
come on
that's not happening
I mean it's all up to what the NRA does
frankly
it's in there the balls the bullets in
their Court
the bullets in their chamber
so many Chad suggested R Kelly gets his
passport I don't think that one's
happening I don't think that ain't
happening I don't think that's happening
I mean Cosby got out
true
that is true man that would be
interesting if we could get Cosby R
Kelly Weinstein out and they could all
have like a support group together would
they you know I feel like they would
have a lot in common the three of them
yeah I mean definitely they could start
a wow they could start a badass three
man and wow
World of Warcraft
ninja apologizes to Pokemon that's not
happening
the podcast gets another strike I mean
that one's 50 50. by the way I think our
strike expires today or at least today
is the last day so it'll be out tomorrow
really let me uh verify that
Jeff sues David and wins that'd be
great Kanye Ethan crossover come on
dobrik's Pizza shuts down
I heard that pizza sucks man I'm still
waiting for one of y'all to bring me a
slice
just swing by well maybe Lena can get a
one she's out doing errands
she apparently they selling full pies
now
let's get ourselves a dobric pie
I don't think the Kanye Ethan crossover
is as far-fetched as you might think
because didn't uh Nick Fuentes talk
about you you know what I think you're
right at a certain point when he was on
his media tour I there was a moment
where it was more likely but he went
back into hiding didn't he now what yeah
he seems to be laying low at the moment
I think I just got remarried oh yeah
he got remarried to like a Kim
Kardashian knockoff is that right Olivia
she isn't she would you consider his new
wife who he just got spontaneously
married to like a Kim K I don't know
Dollar Store much about it let me look
I know how was my campaign and I mean
that with all the peace and love in the
world of course
uh but let's pull up a picture
you think Trisha makeup bro
stop it
the podcast gets natural national news
coverage
okay but no you got to get like uh
I'm good to see the yeah look at I mean
right that's like a camera okay yeah
at least for sure has a Type e
I think his time I think I think his
type is Kim Kardashian yeah yeah
okay although the last girl he was
dating wasn't anything like her Julia
Julia Fox he tried something else he
didn't like it back to the basics we're
gonna stop dissing the Nazis all the
time I wonder if she shares that opinion
she must
so we like to say what's your name
the new wife yeah let's see Bianca so
we're giving Bianca a very uh
enthusiastic Heil and welcome
yo she got us she got a
tighten that up that was Bianca's yeah
so Heil and welcome to the new West
family
uh Bianca
we welcome you to the fold
[Music]
um
the crew will attend Gabe's next
birthday party that's happening we can't
miss the next one bro I can't go through
that again or you guys better go I have
a kid and [ __ ] to do in a babysitter I'm
not gonna have a babysitter on that day
he and you still have the graphic
there we go look at this list it's hard
it's gonna be the same for next year and
don't even get me started with shredder
being sick you expect me to leave my
house for anything so true has kids
longest day ever no I mean come on
General laziness I mean you don't even
need that there this is your list
yeah yeah [ __ ] sorry Gabe
um AV throws up at least once that's
happening that's easy almost happened
yes okay pretty Square first the first
episode back wait what almost made you
Yak uh the the sounding in the sounding
yeah sounding yeah really are you you'll
Yak from visual stimulation uh not
usually usually no I'm okay I usually
visual I just it's usually smells but I
I was like sick and I was coughing
mid-gagging of that combination yeah
yeah I got you it is it is pretty
shocking yeah
what's more shocking a sounding a deep
hard thick sounding or two prolapses
touching oh the sounding for sure
I agree sound yeah the prolapse is kind
of amazing I mean it's the prolapse is
touching is one of the most It's Still
In This Moment In My Life One of the
most shocking things but you're seeing
liquid [ __ ] going a dick hole it's wait
liquid [ __ ] it was like liquid [ __ ] yeah
it's also like you talk about liquid
[ __ ] it's a rod
but like urine or like no it was leaking
like some type of brown that's for sure
what oh my God y'all got on the weirdest
place without yeah
that's worse than the prolapse I don't
know man it doesn't look more painful
listen the prolapse is is something
coming out of of a hole that things are
supposed to come out of right wow even
even if you're eating
it's still moving in the right it's a
one-way Street and it's going in the
right direction it's you're no you're
going again that's supposed to come out
of your ass it doesn't matter I'm
talking about the flow of traffic here
okay and the the flow of traffic with
the sounding you're going the wrong way
on a one-way street right it's
not good
I don't know people are saying it was
probably lubricant
Brown you guys don't know what sounding
lubricant is hello it looks like [ __ ]
looks like I don't know sounds sexy by
the way do you tell Lina to get a Dober
pie if she has time uh I can ask her
I may be fun no
yeah it would be fun I'd be fun to eat
pizza I doubt she'll get in in time but
I'll ask her it's okay if she doesn't
have time just just maybe she's in the
neighborhood I don't know no biggie
cheese thank you fousey's excited
Ethan hikes with Philly D that's up to
Philly D like he's not meeting my
conditions I is trying to get Philly to
even do and he should be honored that we
invite him on this this number one show
in the world sure it's a great honor to
the steamies and not only
has he continually he's ghosting me on
it
I mean what the [ __ ] we're fool
if you're gonna ghost me on that why
don't you ghost me on the thumbnails
you're going to use me abuse me on your
thumbnails but not you want to go on a
hike you got to me you got to do
something for me
Wendy Williams come back I think she
already came back she's making a show
like somebody actually gave her a show
good in that state he's doing better
fact check that no she's coming out with
the new show which is especially hell
yeah she's ill though yeah she was
coming out with a podcast dude that's
gonna be a wild ride brother wait it's a
podcast she's gonna be competing yeah
she has never won the team now Wendy's
going to be pushing the the publish
button herself yeah I'm ready I'm ready
to eat as soon as they add her team's
new emails I am wait yeah we gotta get
around I am trying to promo yeah it's a
podcast we're a podcast it's all the
windy experience she announced it in
July the windy experience yeah oh boy
I'm less I don't know that that's an
explosion oh boy okay it's okay yeah oh
but yeah okay we love you Wendy welcome
back Ethan's dethroned his hairline King
I don't know why you would even write
that
it's disgusting shame on you I was
bullied because I had red hair
2.7 million does that mean we go up or
down what are we at now we're at like
2.8 right or nine okay so we would we
would have to lose another 100 000 right
and there's another one that's that we
hit three million so really there's an
option for moving in either direction
we're way more likely to hit 2.7 huh
because we got a year to go the
unsubbing slowed down a lot in our break
and then when we came back yesterday it
was like we're right back baby
what year is it
I how are people still unsubby like
didn't we get rid of y'all
I think we pissed off a new fan base
every episode that's what I think so
right yeah and we kind of aim high we
don't you know we aim for the rogans and
the the big people but nobody's like
there's nobody who's like oh I want to
watch HD podcast I like this new show I
found nobody
well that's not true no no because you
go to the analytics on Monday and check
out new Subs versus
um uh uh Elite exiting Subs sure okay
let's get the stats on that and if this
is your first time watching the show
today smash that subscribe button that's
right tell me what's your favorite thing
and I'll and I will uh dedicate an
episode to chastising it
different perspectives
and finally Hassan and Ethan debate a
major conservative okay fun so play
along at home you can buy our Bingo
cards have a chance to win a million
bucks
with the QR code
at pay me
and uh [ __ ] you.com far more
yeah you got that Intel I'm in here
right now I'm trying to find I'm seeing
where it tells you how many subscribers
gained or lost but I'm not seeing them
separated so so on the day you should
see a fat loss when when it updated for
Mondays yeah so if you click that dot it
should tell you gained and lost it
doesn't it just says minus it wasn't
that fat 654.
lost on Monday well we're back we're
back baby I mean if you hey if you count
that for you know how many episodes we
do
five five a week baby go let's do the
math on that that's a lot of Subs to be
missing yeah we love it whatever
sayonara bon voyage yeah so anyway guys
uh let's see Justin royland oh brother
oh brother this one's so weird I don't
know what to say man I mean this guy was
like genuinely how am I supposed to act
in this situation like Justin Roiland
hmm
he was
my friend like we literally talked on
the phone
a few weeks ago
now what am I how like what is the
appropriate way for me to to I haven't
talked to him by the way since this
happened I haven't reached out or
anything
and obviously like
um obviously denounce
friendship over
on my end
but like is is it not weird to just go
full blast on him and not pretend like
we have a relationship like do you know
what I mean uh genuinely I understand
what you're saying like genuinely and
and it's not because I don't disagree
it's not because I
don't have the same thoughts about it
that I would with anybody else right I
just like
it just feels weird I I listen not
everybody agrees like obviously we've
seen on Twitter and social media people
pressuring both with this in the Andrew
Calhan situation saying like you need to
say something or whatever personally
I mean both of these dudes are getting
[ __ ] roasted by everybody on the
internet right now yeah
because of the personal history between
you two I don't I don't feel like you
are obligated to like go super hard like
what you just said is fine you denounce
it you're aware of it it's gross
you you hate it you hate that it's
happening
wait that's that's enough you don't have
to like you know harp on it forever
you're not obligated to do that
right right I feel the same way but you
know people get like people turn it into
a whole big thing like oh you're not
willing to call your friends for the
same [ __ ] that you call everyone else
for you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
hypocrite and you don't care it's like
they turn into this whole thing but you
literally did I mean you did do that
like probably not as hard as you do to a
stranger but I feel like that's
understandable
you know um
we should add a category I just realized
uh to the steamies in the biggest perv
because there's actually been a lot of
breakthroughs that's a big category
category this year you copy that in
yeah yeah that would be good well we
went over the categories for the
steamies and it's going to be a huge
show still looking for a co-host
unfortunately
right
yeah
um
well anyway the reason I bring this up
about Justin is because there's this
leaked or it's not leaked it's from an
old podcast he did and this [ __ ] is so
crazy
I literally did the joji take like y'all
have y'all seen this someone posted this
website yes their day on the members
only
somebody pulled a great photo of me
doing the joji
it's super super super wild and I think
it's worth listening to
I don't know
let's do it
let's just jump right into it I mean
okay so I don't I don't know the when
this is from it appears to be old based
on his voice because his voice has kind
of changed he sounds like kind of like
can we too young again 2015 I think I
saw Jesus Christ
I'm not attracted to [ __ ] little kid
bodies I like [ __ ] women but look
I'll say look a [ __ ] 14 year old that
looks like she's 18 and like big titties
and like of course I'm gonna I'm
attracted to that oh yeah
that's pretty wild dude he got so great
dude he this man said [ __ ] that like
should never leave someone's mouth and
that that's part of what's so hot like
hard not to talk about it because in
this case the stuff that's coming out is
the CR some of the craziest [ __ ] I've
ever read or heard
in one of these kinds of situations
where someone's being you know exposed
quote unquote somebody the chat says
it's actually from all the way back in
2012. oh wow the clip is from his old
podcast gvp it's from 2012. so how old
would that have made him at the time
because I think he's in his 40s now so
he I think he was like 30 uh 32 or 30.
okay so he's a he was like a grown grown
grown ass man yeah yeah 32. he was 32.
all right you guys buckle up this is
wild man this shit's crazy I gotta just
be real deal somebody said who is this I
guess
you should for people who don't know who
Justin Roiland is he's the co-creator of
Rick and Morty he does all the voices
for Rick and Morty he has a ton of
projects in the work
but that's where his claim to fame is
that's where most people know him from
yeah he's the guy who goes Joe geez Rick
and then he also does the the Rick voice
Marty Marty pretty good right maybe I'll
replace maybe you know
by the way thank you to our wonderful
donors
day V Davie Ian Avatar 2 takes upset me
you don't see it for the story guys
couldn't it still be a great Cinema
experience with great visuals but also
have a good story that's what I was
saying that's what I was saying I was
like wait wait wait okay no no this is
important huh this is very important
um are they upset that we said that we
liked it or that we didn't know they
don't they don't think that you're
justified in saying well listen let's
separate Ian and I because we we Ian
Ian's like that's a 10 out of 10 movie
I'm like it was like a seven out of 10
Cinema experience like I feel like
there's there's a little bit of a
distance between our reception right Ian
is that fair you guys put 10 in my mouth
here okay well I'm asking if that was
fair so what would you rate it I'd give
it like an eight all right listen listen
we're we're we talked about this a lot
just kidding I just I can't you know
what I mean listen I I don't even know
where we are we're trying to do
something okay yeah let's keep it moving
thank you though and I agree with you
Davey David Whispers
ten dollars for Cam's Golden Voice
started an narration Channel
there it is
thank you I think that's generous I
probably have like a brass Voice or
maybe a tin oh stop that but thank you
if you ham it up it'd be really crazy
too you could do like the Markiplier hi
everybody this is Markiplier he
definitely if you listen to Markiplier
like before he became a YouTuber he'd
probably sound like this hey everybody
it's Mark Markiplier this is my natural
voice you think he's doing a he's doing
a corpse husband yeah definitely Amy he
definitely
for sure hey everybody I gotta start
training my voice hey welcome everybody
it's Ethan Glenn here hey what's going
on everyone yeah
what's going on everyone uh Tatum says
I'm a hairdresser I literally tell all
my clients about H3 thank you God bless
you we need you
yeah
all right and happy Birthday Quinn okay
let's watch this now
well as a race are we that crazy like
when we were [ __ ] 100 years ago it
was little 13 year old girls if they
were built like a woman they were
getting married and having kids and now
we're gonna be all precious about it I
keep using the word precious today
that's the word of the week which is a
movie about a child molester precious
Right Down Syndrome baby yeah exactly so
anyways uh I'm not a pedophile though I
do I'm a pedophile I wait till they're
18 if if if if I'm ever so lucky as to
have this for that dude Justin's advice
for me to get a girl kind of worked out
but you should put a warning by the way
just to put a pin in this this whole
Narrative of like oh we we used to have
sex with 12 year olds that's not true
also him saying if I were to be so lucky
as to get with a teen he's like I will
do 18 if I'm so lucky as to get a team I
think what he was saying was if he's so
lucky to have sex but I think it was cut
off oh I see yeah not that like he needs
any generosity in this situation yeah
um
the thing is I think at the time this
was received as a joke but now that
everything's coming out you're like oh
[ __ ] he was like dead serious right nice
okay I'm sorry you should put a warning
only lasts 48 hours oh because the girl
I said had a nice ass do you remember
when you guys tell her she's got a nice
ass be a man tell him that everybody
thinks was gay yeah be confident act
like you act like you know you're
[ __ ] awesome and if you're like in
fourth grade these girls they're gonna
be blindsided if I could go back and be
a fourth grade kid right now with what I
know oh my God I'd be like walking
around I'd be getting laid every [ __ ]
day gross and it works great and it
would be legal too because I would be a
little kid and he's been practicing on a
fourth grader now so he knows how to do
yeah uh-huh no she's 22.
um she does have braces though I love it
I love the braces it's hot okay uh he
says anyways she said I said had a nice
ass I'm not a pedophile though all right
Jesus Christ didn't really want I'm not
attracted to [ __ ] little kid bodies I
like [ __ ] women but look I'll say
look a [ __ ] 14 year old that looks
looks like she's 18 and like big titties
like of course I'm gonna I'm attracted
to that oh yeah that's the part they
caught me that's where it made me like
whoa yeah
ever why would you say that
a 14 year old with big titties I'm
attracted to her
I'm not this high school girl that I was
hot as [ __ ] tonight
[Laughter]
dude like why did you say that bro golly
that's why this whole Chris Hansen thing
I'm like [ __ ] you man these girls are
like they look they're fully developed
and they're like talking online I want
you to [ __ ] the girls are old men or
women pretend to be to lure the
pedophiles into the house yeah but they
would email photos of what they look
like and the ones I saw were like that
girl's fully [ __ ] up yeah come on back
in like how are we literally like yeah
as a race are we that crazy like when we
were he's on EDP stuff
like I can't believe somebody actually
said all this yeah
on on record
eggs
what was on the agenda tonight
now I find the
I find the Catch a Predator thing a
little bit questionable not because I
think want to [ __ ] the girls by the way
uh it's because I feel like sometimes
they're entrapping these guys a little
bit you know what I mean
well you know why they stopped making it
right somebody killed them literally
yeah
the whole thing was really [ __ ] it
did I mean the show was dark of course
it's dark yeah I mean it's pretty don't
you take a seat right over there
exploitative funny kind of gross way to
to make entertainment but um
I think at least there was at least
there was some of those dudes and I'm
not excusing their behavior but like I
think they're like lonely virgins and
then I think they reach out to him and
go hey I'm 14 and I'm looking for a
friend and uh oh you're hot and like
obviously it's [ __ ] insane to go meet
a 14 year old but like I feel like it's
a little entrapment like I don't know if
he would have thought that out by
himself yeah I don't isn't the whole
thing that they reach out to them I
don't think so I think so well maybe not
I don't know I don't think so I think
their methods were super I never really
watched it so I'm not worse we're not
too familiar with their with the setup
yeah I don't know
people are saying they're not being
entrapped
well I think it's funny well at least I
didn't say that I want to that I think
the kids are hot
I'm drunk
um
here we go let's move on
I think you guys are wrong by the way
but whatever who cares I'm not gonna
[ __ ] die on this hill
thank you
I don't care uh let's talk about has Cav
yeah oh by the way I wanted to ask you
guys think he's gonna survive this
because I heard
I talked to somebody who knows him who
thinks he's going to be fine through
this
and I was like what wow wait
like career-wise or like everything was
about like career-wise
uh Adult Swim hasn't even made a
statement yet so I don't know Presley
thank you for the 20 gifts I don't think
so
there's no way uh I mean I I don't know
the details of the the case against him
or whatever but it sounds pretty serious
and I mean that alone I mean that would
probably hurt his career to uh go to
prison
right so
a lot of the hinges on a cancellation
Factor aside like this is Way Beyond
cancellation this is like he might be
going to prison for I'm surprised that
Adults Swim or Cartoon Network hasn't
said anything yeah that is kind of nuts
I mean or at least say they're panicking
oh yeah for sure say something like
there's an investigation going on I
don't think they've said a damn thing by
the way did you guys know that Justin
broadland was actually caught uh in Rick
and Morty creeping on the high school
students
so no cookies for you oh no
yeah pretty crazy they were trying to
tell us even back then
um
cavcv the man who was suing me a giant
piece of [ __ ] a bit of huge failure and
both personal and business
it was pointed out that he looks like
serial killer Todd
Cole look at this [ __ ] so who oh
that looks like Harvey Weinstein yeah
yeah dude did Harvey Weinstein got some
murders
look at this Jeffrey dahmers look at
this the resemblance is unfreaking
planning this was actually posted on its
own and I by myself was watching a true
crime video and sent it to my friend and
said this looks exactly like capcav what
did this guy do what are his crimes he
killed seven people between 2003 and
2016 in North Carolina also he was
charged with uh why do you you are fast
on that one boy this is my job what do
you always hold on let me do the no
thing oh you you did research though on
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] it came with facts
go ahead good I'm glad thanks for doing
your job he kidnapped someone he R
worded someone oh my God yeah
bad dude Drive Angry
do you guys think they might have gotten
the wrong guy that's what I'm expecting
and it's pure speculation right yeah
yeah
like I wonder if we can add to the
website something about the likeness and
of course not making any allegations for
speculation in fact the crimes what year
did these crimes occur between 2003 and
2016. so how old would have kavka have
been oh you would have been an adult I
believe didn't he start relativity in
like 2004 or five okay that is
interesting actually yeah simply just
one pitching the putting the idea out
there just putting out he was funny no
no we're not putting no we're not
putting ideas anywhere love it's a
speculation yeah right it was 29 in 2003
so 29. this man looks about 29. 14 year
old Natalie Portman was he did they use
like a police sketch to find the guy
where did cabcap live back then
we're here in L.A he's from here and
these crimes happened where uh North
Carolina well you know you never want to
do you're killing where you live yeah
it's number one number one yeah South
Carolina South Carolina North Carolina
whatever
same thing
yeah I'm just saying uh Jeffrey Dahmer
my the detectives might want to take a
second look at them
right all right um we got to do ads all
right let's thank our savonsors today we
have the wonderful
the lovely honey
yes we love honey folks
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer
they got it on the iPhone now for using
Safari no matter where you are on the
internet there's a good shot
that Honey's got coupons for that
website I'm talking about
groceries I'm talking about food I'm
talking about clothing I'm talking about
gadgets Electronics
[Music]
you're going to be saving money and it's
like magic it's a plug-in you plug it in
at checkout it automatically scours the
internet for a promo code and applies
the best one of fines to your cart
here's how it works you're shopping at
your favorite site and when you check
out the honey button appears all you
have to do is Click apply coupon wait a
few seconds this honey surges first
coupon you can find for that site and
Bob if Bob isn't your uncle
uh you'll watch the price drop magically
Bob's the uncle
Bob is your uncle yeah I was the reason
I say Bob's your uncle is because I
found out the English say that and I
found I just found it so absurd like
what's Bob who's Bob's your uncle
like have you heard of that Olivia you
look confused
I mean you you say what are we talking
about Bob's your office and there you
have it
yeah in the UK and perhaps your uncle
and there there you have it I know it's
crazy that's why I like it it's like
crazy I was like oh Baba I've never
heard that guy before Bob's your uncle
Ethan says it like once an episode I I
choose to disregard I guess
it goes yeah it's
Origins are uncertain but a common
theory is that the expression Rose after
conservative prime minister Robert
gascoigne Cecil the third Marquee of
Salisbury
Bob apparently it just went by Bob
uh appointed his nephew Lord Bob Arthur
Balfour as the chief secretary for
Ireland in 1887. how as an act of
nepotism ah which was important
than ever nepo Bobby whatever other
qualifications Balfour might have had
Bob's your uncle was seen as the
conclusive one
oh my God see I my I assumed it was like
um
everybody's got an uncle named Bob and
it's just as obvious as Bob's your uncle
Bobby and the uncle but there's like fat
lore to that
bat War
nepotism lore okay
anyway Bob's your uncle you're going to
be saving money on honey
and you don't even need nepotism it's
for everybody yep
man here's a coupon we saved on uh this
website Z
it's probably Ila she is Eli has saved
so much money I can't tell you guys and
it's money you don't expect to save
either you're at the checkout and boom
this one was 9.50 out of 45 bucks free
money forget about it and what's
exciting honey doesn't work on your
doesn't just work on desktop also works
on your iPhone just activate it on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
so if you already have honey you could
be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show get PayPal
honey for free
at joinhoney.com H3 that's joinhoney.com
H3 we love honey thank you thank you to
our wonderful sponsor
and everybody loves
stamps baby
[Music]
okay I'm feeling this
dude there ain't nothing more romantic
than a stamp boy
nothing get me in the mood like some
good discounted convenient postage
um
that means you got more time for loving
yes January means dealing with customer
emails well you know what we need more
time and we need more postage stamps.com
has teamed up with the post office to
get you massive discounts on mailing and
shipping up to 86 reason number one boom
cheaper massive discounts okay
reason number two you print the postage
from your home use a digital scale you
weigh it you print the postage put it on
the box here's the great part you drop
it off or they come and pick it up
reason number two is cheaper and it's
more convenient what more do you want to
know about stamps
for more than 20 years stamps.com has
been indispensable for over a million
businesses get access to USPS and UPS
Services you need to run your business
right from uh your computer anytime day
or night no lines no traffic no waiting
we always mention about Dan's girlfriend
is a stamp.com Enthusiast yeah
enthusiasts customer proselytizer
um
other words like that simple legend
legend yeah she uses stamps.com for a
small business and uh
what's awesome you just do it from home
you print the postage you put in a
mailbox or Dropbox or you get your front
door and a lot of bing boom you know
what I mean Bob's your uncle Bob is your
mother freaky blueberry
Zach you got me on that one
uh I can't right now but you know okay
as long as you I I I'm yeah you're with
me yeah
uh yeah start the new year by Saving
serious money on mailing and shipping
get started with stamps.com today sign
up with promo code H3 for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
free postage and a free digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code H3 thank you thank you
with peace and love
lots of love extra love yeah
thank you
oh yes
we got an update from Lena from the vet
no yogurt and honey
so
that was almost exciting
what I don't know they really expect me
to feed him like carrots like I don't
know he's not gonna eat carrots I mean
try I do I have been I got like hungry
enough you know probably eat it
I don't want to bomb everyone out every
time I talk about this but yeah the
kidney disease makes him less hungry so
it's like a and if he doesn't eat
obviously bad things happen
foreign
anyway
to call back to the lookalikes I got to
ask Ethan are you wearing a gray shirt
today because somebody on the Reddit
says you look like Bobby Hill because
you're giving full body
dude that should crack me up that one is
that one is good I admit that one's
funny
I'm wearing a I mean it's it's like
dirty black
skin like that He even wears the shorts
like you okay that is pretty funny I
can't even lie I see the resemblance
dude Bobby Hill is a great character
that's not that's not too insulting I
love Bobby he's been my Twitter Banner
for like they're not saying my
personalities like Bob yeah just what
you look like I look like Bobby right
yeah that's my purse
yeah Bobby Hill's awesome
damn it bobber
anyway moving on thank you thank you
oh god dude Prince Harry's book is my
new favorite thing of the Year boy you
guys I cannot get enough of it oh by the
way thank you thank you to Bella Simmons
you are
so wild Bella how many is she doing it
thank you so much I hope you're like
super rich dude
what kind of how much do you get 50 Subs
Legend she does it like every day
uh yeah so
we discovered how crazy uh Prince
Harry's
voiceover was if you can update us a
little bit uh Zach my penis was
oscillating between extremely sensitive
and borderline traumatized the last
place I wanted to be was Frost nipples
down this man is trying some home
remedies including one recommended by a
friend she dodged me to apply Elizabeth
Arden cream
my mom used that on her lips you want me
to put that on my todger It Works Harry
found a tube and the minute I opened it
the smell transported me through time
I thought as if my mother was right
there in the room
and I took a smidge and applied it down
there dude that is the sit one of the
best
I'd be hard-pressed to find a better
audio sound bite well uh I guess a
little in but I I matched up the
Peterson and the Hillary oh I'm so
excited these are my two faves let's
hear it they go back and forth my penis
is oscillating between extremely
sensitive the genital region was exposed
dimly the last place I wanted to be was
Frost Nippers stand it had the
appearance of a thick mat of hair
including one recommended by a friend
she dodged me to apply Elizabeth
ardencreem she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly she walked over to me
with a handful of pubic hair compacted
into something resembling a large artist
it is crazy
it works Harry trust me he'll pushed
this at my face I raised my arm several
times to deflect her hand found a tube
and the minute I opened it the smell
transported me through time
I thought as if my mother was right
there I let her have her way
down there oh my god dude shout out to
these two legends man I didn't want to
be in wikiwaka land until I took my
todger and did a willy-nilly on it I
told you Mike Taja
anyway so here's more actually uh from
The Prince Harry audiobook some of y'all
just got to listen to this for us and
just send us listen I'm not I'm [ __ ]
opposed to this Prince Harry book
I might be joining a book club where we
read this oh really okay so yes you're
gonna join a book club someone my friend
posted on their story if anyone wants to
do a book club for it and I did reply
great I want you to join that book club
too done and just put a thumbnail
whenever he talks about his dick or
whatever
his mom thinking about his mom and his
dick anyway here's more from Harry I
spent a lot of late 2003 sitting high in
the saddle watching a wiener while
sucking a smoko and dreaming of my next
Tucker I spent a lot of late 2003. what
the [ __ ] did you just say
I was wait wait wait Ian can you
translate I'm dreaming of my next Tucker
ah this is outside of my what you're not
fluent enough
this is a different form of of Brit okay
I was sucking on a willywalker walking
my gym job
and then I hopped in my knick-knack
Cadillac and gave a dog a bone are you
speaking what language is that smoker
like is that like smoke like cigarette
is like that's the only thing yeah I
assume so let's try to decode this yeah
I spent a lot of late 2003 sitting high
in the saddle watching a wiener while
sucking a smoko okay watching a wiener
wait I mean what else could it be other
than a dog yeah everyone is saying this
is a Australian slang
that family's known for having corgi
dogs which I guess could resemble a
wiener dog the context doesn't make a
lot of sense because he's like what are
you sat there watching your dog well you
know watching a wiener
also that's just a weird way to refer to
your dog watching a wiener nobody said
can I do an A B real quick isn't it
clear that he's doing this for just
attention or like no he's he's being
funny there's no way he talks like this
well uh no that's where you're wrong the
English for [ __ ] wild yeah
these people used to run the country
and now he's doing like a sucking a
smoking talks like this bro I hate the
breaker too but the English of some
goofy [ __ ] [ __ ] goofy they are
man there's certain place like eras in
England where
let's straight up
I'm hap I'm hopping in my bed my my bin
my wheelie Benny that's what they call
their cars I've not been in my willy
Binion and going to my working doggy
place I'm seeing more and more people
say oh that slang is Australian so I
assume it was from a time in his life
where he spent some time in Australia oh
yeah she is
the principles Australia as well right
um what I mean he oh yeah the whole
Commonwealth right yeah all the
Commonwealth Nations so
um I also did so maybe picked up on some
of that Aussie slang while he was living
down there oh that's not your ID
I love that all right but here let's try
to decode this I spent a lot of late
2003 sitting high in the saddle watching
a wiener while sucking a smoko and
dreaming of my next Tucker so what's his
next Tucker like does that
means Tucker's dinner that means dinner
Oh I thought it would be like his next
[ __ ] yeah that's what I thought it was
Smoker's a cigarette Tucker's wait why
is he dreaming of his next meal like
that's just what is he talking about my
next time he's dreaming of his next
Tucker wait watching a wiener so is he
looking at a [ __ ] hot dog he's like
okay so now we have the interesting
interpretation he's smoking and he's
watching hot dogs cook he's in a movie
theater right he's working a concession
and he's thinking about what flavor
flavor the hot dog that he wants he's
watching the cut the hot dog spin and
he's hungry both these things are very
phallic looking too uh cigarette weiner
you know
I was doing I was doing the tiki wikis
at the movie box
Wonka my Dew dropped my next Tucker
all right Prince Harry we love it he was
crossing Australia on horseback
oh that hurts the todgers okay wait let
me try that again then I spent a lot of
late 2003 sitting high in the saddle
okay so he's literally on a horse yeah
I figured that was the case while
sucking watching a wiener on a horse
though that doesn't make sense a dog no
it's I think it's like a lost person or
someone that's confused a wiener that's
I've seen I don't know I've seen a bunch
of different definitions definitions I'm
being a wiener right now I can't it's
much different yeah bro you gotta tone
down the slang a little bit because I
think a lot of Americans are buying this
Roger watching a wiener while sucking a
smoko and dreaming of my next Tucker I
spent a lot of late all right shout out
Prince that's like the most print [ __ ]
ever by the way yeah yeah my life was so
difficult I was traveling across
Australia by horseback I found a tube
and the minute I opened it the smell
transported me through time I thought as
if my mother was right there in the room
I let her have her I was on a horseback
it was an arduous journey and thank God
I had my five servants with me smoko
took Harry all my goods in my smokers
and my touches I told you
yes all the inhabitants
were screaming and shouting at me like I
was a God
does he really say booyakasha yeah why I
told her to say what the [ __ ] is that
from it's in the video hello he's an Ali
G uh
oh
yeah
that's awesome
that's crazy
oh I love this this is the best thing
is cow
okay okay that makes sense why was a
wiener be a cow y'all get your [ __ ]
straight
you go cow style well hot dogs are made
out of pork cows sometimes sometimes
yeah it's true right I'm Muslim instead
of mine because young catalog Sexes I
think it I think it's weaner as if uh
like weaning like you know
yeah yes okay it was like a young cow
I'm kind of putting this together a
little bit he was looking at this
dinner now that we know what it means
breasts but you know what we're like
we're like uh
we're like Napoleon going to Egypt
trying to like Napoleon hieroglyphs yeah
Napoleon swam never want to forget that
we need a uh yeah he who we swam there
we need the Rosetta Stone to decode this
crazy Taja
anyway shout out Prince Harry we are
very happy and proud for you it's good
stuff I'm glad you can finally live a
quiet life out of the media spot life
just just like you wanted oh yeah he
finally found the piece and uh obscurity
he was looking yeah exactly what they
and now finally only him and his wife
will talk about his his
what would we call his penis you know
wiener I don't even know anymore yeah it
seems like it sounds like all the words
in her penis are taken up by some other
Concepts
and now finally my wife and me will be
the only ones to talk about my Taja
while sucking a smoker you know if Queen
Elizabeth heard him say Taja she slapped
the [ __ ] out of it oh yeah
rightfully so
I heard she was super violent
she's Queen Elizabeth I think she was
abusive verbally and physically
what is she gonna sue me you can't see
one and you're dead if you're dead you
cannot be sued for defamation and I'm
just today right here she was a pedo uh
they're they're a family could sue can't
they I'm just kidding no they cannot
think about the state you cannot that
Fame a dead person dead dinosaurs uh in
in American law what are they going to
sue me in England yeah what the [ __ ] are
they gonna do to me better off with your
head I'm saying [ __ ] the crown [ __ ]
[Music]
no but actually you can't defame a dead
person I'm almost certain about that but
she's not a pet owner made that up at
least you're almost certain you were
very smart a moment ago under common law
and according to the definition deceased
individuals cannot be defamed you see
he's dead
by the way is kind of crazy right
because you can definitely defame a dead
person like and their family has to live
with the consequence of it some states
do permit uh slander to be brought on
behalf of the estate of the deceit yeah
because with the Michael Jackson for
example those people were suing the
Michael Jackson estate right not for
confirmation but they they were but the
family is countersuing I think oh is
that still going through Court
I think it was dropped
The Jacksons dropped it no the the
counter suit the the original case got
thrown out by the judge
you want to talk about it because too
much time had passed not because he's
innocent
because one of the guys was his lead
witness in his initial uh allegations
was part of it and then they tried to
open it back up and I think after the
documentary they opened it back up at
one point but it got tossed again wait
are you saying it got tossed why well
the first time I believe is because one
of the guys in the documentary one of
the accusers was
uh Wade oh okay was uh his lead witness
in his 2005 case for Michael Jackson in
defense of him so and he like sweared
under oath oh yeah yeah but so he would
be was he a kid perjuring himself no he
was adult
yeah I think so but I think it was
thrown out because of the time limit
because there's a statute of limitation
on diddling
apparently is there such a limitation on
diddling
shouldn't be
anyway shout out to the queen who's
[ __ ] in a box
I think you were confused she's not a
pedo she only knighted and was friends
with petos like Jimmy Seville right I
actually raised them and that's a matter
of fact that's not even enough Jim will
fix it yeah Jim will fix you right up
little boy
I heard that uh Queen Elizabeth
requested to be buried alongside Jimmy
Savelle so apparently friends till the
end
Bradley Martin oh man
oh Brad man sweet Bradley
but
Bradley went on uh the dumbest podcast
in the world
run by the two biggest [ __ ] morons on
the planet Earth
Brendan Schaub oh the vibe right now I
was like where who is he talking about
here this man this is the guy who uh
these were the two guys who went after
Bobby Lee during that whole big thing I
remember I remember this dude is accused
of being a
okay this is all allegations I'm just
saying but this guy's been accused of
collaborating with he he was allegedly
involved with some of Chris Delia's
allegations or people speculated that oh
that he was like the other guy in like
the threesomes that happened or like
there was one account where the girl
said Chris said you have got to go to my
friend's house and blow him right there
allegedly or speculated by people
of course I have no idea that it was him
but I think he has other allegations too
but he's a piece of [ __ ] uh and
abandoned jobs a giant [ __ ] [ __ ]
some say the biggest nice thighs though
you know they got something the nicest
some say the nice some say the diceiest
but the good news is Joe Rogan loves him
so anyway uh the fighter and the kid
Bradley was invited on this podcast and
uh that the issue of Andrew came up
again
and I just I don't know how people are
still defending him I mean after all we
watched on Monday it's [ __ ] it's
crazy but here they are talking about it
so I've been trying to reach out to
Wadley and I'm not giving up Hope on
Wadley
no I wanted to have him call in today
but I think he's ghosting me I don't
know why I think he's mad at me again
but I had a conversation that
conversation with him the podcast was
great I think it was it was I I think
he's mad that like we we maybe cause
friction in the group because we were
like Wadley rules and all and then all
those other guys suck and it's got to be
weird I think for him and maybe some of
the guys especially stymie
we haven't had any nice words for uh
uh you know Steve will do it and we I
thought we kind of squashed things with
him and then Steve will do it's not
involved in this he's my bestie right
now I was gonna say that what's the I
always forget his name the main milk guy
Kyle Kyle Kyle wasn't he even like uh
saying you were really funny I didn't
compliment you and you were like oh I
love this guy now he's my best friend
yeah yeah that's a Vibe right now I'll
die for him all that yeah yeah yeah we
like how he handled the end of his
podcast yeah yeah those are all true so
well yeah this whole side of the
internet you know they're all anti-h3 so
definitely
probably tough for him
yeah I think there's where it's a weird
thing but you know um
I think there's now oh see this was
going to be us and then they had to go
we these guys are just playing with me
y'all playing man this could be us I'm
just spitting facts I would bring such a
[ __ ] full sent vibe
you are way more of a full sender than
These Guys these guys don't know [ __ ]
about full sending how many of them have
shaved off their eyebrows for for a
stupid joke for a matrix joke probably
zero definitely not steiny
not even a million
yeah but um
um so here's Wadley on the fighter and
the kid and this just came out like I
guess yesterday yep so this is brand new
but I had a conversation that
conversation with him the podcast was
great I think it was it was a really
like good podcast and then I talked to
him for like about three hours after
like No cameras nothing we're just
sitting at a table talking and uh dude
yeah he's a good dude and see the thing
is like you know I hear these
allegations and stuff people say I don't
know
um the truth behind it all uh I can't
speak on that but I heard you though I
don't know him that well no yeah I know
and the thing is though the at the core
like how could anyone know I didn't feel
like because that's their line that's
what they all want to know look nobody
knows he's literally gonna go to prison
and get sent this nobody knows what
happened I mean who's to say other than
everyone around you and Andrew himself
in his own words yeah repeatedly yes
yeah bring me pizza how can you know
anything honestly at the end of the day
it's kind of a compelling world view
that's a very interesting some
existential ontological question I'm
having an existential dreads trying to
figure out philosophical question how do
I know anything what do you mean by no
right what does it mean is it you know
what is it yeah what is not what is what
does it mean how Andrew Tate is innocent
how could anybody know anything
how can you know anything before you
know what the word no means
50 50. all right let's keep going I can
normally spend some time with them I
spent like three hours talking to
someone you're gonna know uh this guy's
kind of they're just kind of scummy
right yeah there was nothing he said
that was that is a high level sociopath
of course he's going to manipulate you
and no offense I love you Bradley but oh
I'm not even gonna say it we're friends
but you know I was gonna say right
yeah like oh he's just scummy like
everything of the conversation we would
have was just like was actually about
the world and as it sits and how it is I
think a lot of his messaging is good but
it's over kind of the the negative stuff
overshadows people like to say that what
I don't think they have any idea what
part of the message I would I would like
I would like to ask him I would like
some specifics and he would probably say
something like oh well self-help which
is just like go to the gym workout okay
so just the most basic [ __ ] that
everyone says everywhere for years
that's groundbreaking no a lot of it's
great stuff man yeah
I don't know if it was some wild [ __ ]
and then they just the media runs with
that that's what it is I don't think
it's overshadows
this is so insane
the media runs with the wild [ __ ] which
over which overshadows unjustly that he
tells people to exercise I feel like
he's just pulling anything and
everything out of his Arsenal on his
head to just throw at this conversation
to defend him I think Shob is barely
functioning mentally he's doing a word
I think you're right I he just wants to
participate I want to be a little bit
charitable to Bradley uh a lot of these
podcasts and I wouldn't be surprised if
theirs is one that does this Bank
episodes a lot this could have been from
a while ago this could I I don't know
that I haven't watched it maybe there's
nothing I want to believe that I I I
love them because him saying like I
don't know anything about that I'd feel
like he wouldn't say that now because
it say when it was shot I mean that's
probably two giving him something about
it but yeah a lot of it those type of
podcasts they'll they'll block shoot a
shitload of episodes and then release
them over a couple months and so this
could have been a while ago yeah by the
way this guy Brian Callan has as
allegations that date back to 1990 well
a woman said he she he R worded her
again those are just 90 those are just
allegations and even just to be honest
I'm not even familiar with them so it's
all speculation and allegations with
peace and love Brian Callan best friends
with Chris Dalia by the way yeah
I'm only giving I'm only thinking that
with Bradley because he's the man he
wouldn't betray us and because we saw
that other clip recently where he did
bring up the evidence to the nelk dudes
which happened as a result of your
conversation so I I feel like that what
he's saying now doesn't really make
sense unless the timeline is I can tell
you exactly what it's from you can yeah
um I found a tick tock they reacted to a
Bradley's and it says from 20 hours ago
so yeah and it's new content I mean but
no I gotta I gotta find a tick tock to
make sure so give me a sec wait how are
you gonna they on on their show they're
showing a tick tock from 20 hours ago so
I'm gonna go to a stick talk oh oh and
see when that detective a b unstoppable
that's worse good call the in this
episode they address his falling out
with Steve will do it and that's fresh
yeah it's because he didn't go to okay
so never mind it's from which two days
ago well there you go Bradley
we tried gladly
and and uh London schlob yeah so okay so
now it all flips it's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you don't know
anything about it you you had like hours
long conversation with him about it I
really want to send him the video that
we watched on Monday with the criminal
attorney
but I think he I don't think he's
answering my text anymore
did you text him I texted him last night
I said hey do you want to call on the
show tomorrow because I really want to
talk to you maybe he's
he just ignored me
he had one really weird request for me
I don't know if it's weird or maybe it's
cool actually but it was unexpected he
texted me a few days ago and said hey um
will you put me in touch with Ela I want
her to come on my podcast that's cool
wait I like it that would never happen
hell no yeah I mean I listen and I said
sure I'll ask her and I did I'd click it
they better fear but that that's like a
weird mashup Bradley and Ela but I think
it was nicely offered I think it's nice
that he asked yeah I think it was nice
too it was thoughtful
speaking of thoughtful here he is
talking about Andrew Tate because of the
media yes yeah because they want it's
like they want they do want that now
like I guess for whatever their reasons
are like
it's just a weird thing because from my
perspective looking at it as he just
garnered so much popularity so fast and
that's such a massive like he got on
Twitter after after he was kicked off
all the platforms he got on Twitter in
like two days he had two million
followers yeah yeah he has almost five
million followers there's a whole
movement like the sigma movement among
these dude you cannot say no dumb [ __ ]
this this
man
it was like such a joke
unironically the sigma movement
oh that's too much oh too much [ __ ] this
guy's like 52. he is
we talking about Sigma movements when
you're 50 bro just can't
young men who uh basically follow him
but they but if you actually look at a
lot of the movement it looks very
positive it's like you know work out be
healthy high value male exactly that's
Andrew Tate high value mail
which is by the way like some weird
fallacy based on their perception of
their crazy perception of women being
like pathetic materialistic like easy to
manipulate weirdos
sex dolls
right thing so a lot of his message
feels yeah like it's it's very positive
and then you have the whole other thing
that's like touted as like he's a
misogynistic pig that's what they do
though but so so they're one of them
these writers these writers who already
have made up their mind will say
misogynistic you know uh influencer and
that's how you get branded and so they
just put a label on you right away and a
lot of it was just theatrics so I don't
know I haven't listened to enough of him
yeah I mean I don't know I don't know
anything about what I just watched a
video on Monday of him like ins clearly
two say he's not misogynistic I mean you
might as well just say Hitler wasn't
anti-semitic at this point you know
that's a big misconception historically
I haven't looked into it by the way it's
just the media it's all self-report I
mean why would you ride so hard for this
dude if you don't know like what's
what's the what's the trade-off the
reason is that they're fans all of
Andrew Tay because they're all like
manosphere weirdos and they know if they
even question a little bit like Bradley
did they're gonna catch a ton of [ __ ]
people are going to say horrible things
like he's a snake and all this nonsense
and uh it's they don't want to take that
on I feel like if they write off uh Tate
for trafficking they think that that
means they're writing him off for their
uh sexist ideas too but they don't they
don't want their fans to to stop being
sexist so I think part of it is also
that they see their own behavior in
Andrew for sure like yeah that's that's
right and that's cool yeah yeah I'm not
wrong
it's the women who are wrong right it's
the women who are saying that they want
us to change that are wrong right I just
had this thought earlier that everyone
who claims you know talking about the
Matrix they're all trying to keep things
the same where men could be misogynistic
and women can't say anything and they
get away with it that's that's the
Matrix of them keeping them keeping
things the way they've always been
making their first sense right so
they're Pro Matrix they're not pro they
are the Matrix yeah I mean that's the
they want status quo that's the exactly
how much we've talked about Andrew Tate
so much and I really have to say that
it's really a compelling topic like this
has really unveiled some incredible
some really incredible things about the
nature of our society and about genders
and [ __ ] like that we're still
dissecting this
that's the game
that's the guy I guess that is the game
anyway I'm just sad [ __ ] it's so sad
that we didn't get to see Andrew Tate
Jordan Peterson interview
you think so
he'll go visit him in prison yeah look
look we just don't know
visit with Michaela 15 years in prison
for r word and and like sex driving we
don't know we don't know we don't know
what we don't know
all right so there's I don't know
so there's always more to this like his
take on Tesla yeah the the mortise
stories that he did way worse [ __ ] but I
but anyway there it is uh
oh what the [ __ ] somebody posted this
yesterday
on fighter in the kids subreddit which
is dedicated
to hating them yeah welcome to Chang's
age three
yourself and get some orange chicken bro
I have no idea they have this whole
lingo that I don't understand I had a
car but they called it man
good job guys
shout out fighter and the kid or Chang's
or you know join the orange chicken or
whatever
bring me pizza free pizza right Brian
Callan is born in the 60s
old is that dude that's like 60. oh man
he's 60. he's pushing 60 dude what's his
exact age okay he's 55.
that man's 55 talking about Sigma yeah
the sigma movement Sigma balls
wow what a loser
once I'm 55 I'm just gonna hide
I'm just gonna put I'm just gonna save
my house and never leave Chad said he's
got dementia
probably
oh somebody says
I'm Noah late but I used to work at a
pet store just food for dogs
and they sell renal support food I have
that
I got it from the vet Frozen and that's
the closest thing I've gotten Shredder
to eating
um but I have to mix bits of chicken in
it or he he just won't do it so
hi okay I'm not gonna lie I'm like on
the verge of a panic attack this whole
show
but I'm pulling through
um having existential crisis when I
start thinking about uh what does it
mean to be x what does it mean to know
anything
um
yeah also so Steve will do it and
Bradley are having a falling out because
they were supposed to come on the
podcast together but I guess they
actually did fall out
really this isn't like I don't think
it's a meme no it's I think it's in
reference to Steve not coming to
Bradley's gym opening yeah and they were
supposed like
I read something where they were
supposed to own it together but then
they didn't and then Steve didn't show
up so it seems like it's half
professional half personal well Brad did
tweet something that's like yo don't
trust anybody they're all just out for
money like some serious grievance thing
but what he tweeted on a race sadly
because I was going to signal boost the
[ __ ] out of this
he says I lied Steve did jerk off
bro why'd you erase that because you
know he got a phone call right away oh
stop it it's obviously a joke no no but
Steve was probably like delete delete it
oh it's such a good tweet Brad you
[ __ ] up deleting that
23 is crazy man this year is nuts off to
a crazy ass start for me
yeah also congratulations to Aiden Ross
speaking of Andrew Tate who just got his
conjugal visit rights so that's exciting
uh Andrew continues his Grooming by the
way that's all this is I've just filled
my visitation form besides my lawyers
I'm allowed five visitors for our family
members and the fifth is Aiden Ross
so what's going on here honestly
is that he feels he's starting to lose
Aiden as more and more terrible things
come out
and obviously I've had it back and forth
with Aiden where he's been kind of
forced to confront some of these
uncomfortable truths about his best
friend and I think he's just doubling
down on the grooming that or he wants a
conjugal visit today I feel uh gay well
in the video he said listen if you have
a cam girl you gotta sleep with them you
just have to even if you don't want to
because they're not going to stay loyal
otherwise so I think Nathan is one of
his cam girls yeah I think Andrew's
[ __ ] Aiden he may not want to may not
even be gay but
we're branching out he's got to keep
ending yes he's got to keep him local
he's got to keep him loyal dude Zach
that sound bite was so [ __ ] perfect
play that again
we are straight
dude I can't believe the amount of I am
gay sound bites we have can you do you
have a mashup of that yet like all of
them uh all four of them together I just
want to hear him like oh I mean I can
play though yeah I want to hear Boom
Boom Boom Boom okay one second
let me just go man okay so here is
fousey I felt gay and then here is uh
Cuomo I am gay
and then here is uh the FIFA dude today
I feel uh gay
and then here is the uh if you're
Christian we are Jewish we are Muslim we
are Hindu we are religious we are
secular we are gay we are straight we
are
these make me so happy can we do a poll
I want to know which is the greatest of
we'll have a little bit of a mini Sound
by tournament here
let's get those up Dan and we're gonna
see which is the greatest I am gay sound
bite can we
do exactly this what we've done this
before the soundbite tournament
yeah we did this this is a category I
think it's going to be a blowout I'm gay
I felt good I don't think so okay you
think fousey's gonna win but Cuomo's is
so funny I am gay that one's so good I
am gay I am gay also the way I feel yeah
the FIFA one's crazy good we are gay we
are straight
straight
what are the others oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] today I feel uh katari FIFA guy oh
the FIFA guy
I am black just fousey I am black
I am Jewish FIFA guy I am disabled dude
I love that [ __ ] I am gay it makes me so
[ __ ] happy Chad spamming about the
Trump one too we got that too Zach what
was the last one oh yeah include the
Trump one there's four options you can't
do Hakeem Jeffrey so then here let's get
rid of the
the guy who did that long speech yeah
the people guy Trump Cuomo fousey yeah
what is the best we have to keep our
country gay people I'm gay there's so
much good they're all so funny we have
to keep our country gate
I am gay all right I am gay roll through
them as as we vote here today I feel uh
gay not so good I felt gay I am gay we
have to keep our country gay people
can't decide
they're all so special to me I am gay
we have to keep our customers it's not
even close see I wasn't gonna vote foosi
I'm like over his I would have voted
Cuomo I think Cuomo's the Cuomo one is
so [ __ ] funny also the Trump one's
amazing the Trump one's amazing well I
think what makes the Trump on him is
just that
what is that like
oh [ __ ] I am gay all right it's it ain't
even close
all right I guess fousey stays on top
okay congratulations
gay dude come on I felt gay
yeah so congratulations to Aiden Ross
for getting the coveted conjugal visit
from Andrew he's got it keep you loyal
somehow right
[Applause]
love that thank you thank you
um
did we not watch this of Brantley
embarrassing Kim
we did not really queen queen it was
over break as much as Keem thinks that
I'm watching him 24 7. he doesn't
understand we have a subreddit people
post this it looks so good so so let me
set this up this man is so pathetic he's
doing this show I guess with his
girlfriend and uh he's so desperate to
dunk on us he's now he's talking about
ab's controversy with the [ __ ]
secretary guard Last Summer
yeah it's not even uh not even remotely
recent no it was it was like six months
ago maybe seven minutes so interesting
that he and his narrative is that uh
you're trying to get this poor old man
fired did we really not talk about the
feeling we have this exact conversation
we did not know this is gold I was
showing everyone I saw it for the first
time yesterday correct whoa [ __ ] up so
can you imagine that's his take on this
oh poor a b is trying to get this old
guy to lose his job what no no no no
it's worse it's worse than that it's way
way what's his action because there's
two you'll see but there's two levels to
like the criticism right there's
there's oh a b shouldn't have you know
contacted this guy's boss and tried to
get him in trouble with work that's
that's like one level okay and you can
be you know you can debate that but then
there's a b was totally in the wrong to
be skateboarding that's dangerous oh
dude he's taking the game is taking that
like it's not even about getting the guy
fired that's what a hooligan riding his
skateboard around
he's actually willing to sound like such
a boomer [ __ ] old [ __ ] let's watch
it because it's so [ __ ] funny well
anyway what what's interesting is that
Brantley
she can't dude I think brantley's taking
a huge dub and it's unfortunate for
Queen Brantley that she's got wrangled
into this relationship with Kim you know
but we St and from the beginning we
stand and we love and we respect
Brantley people are saying you watch
this on a membership I think some people
may be confused because he's talked
about this multiple times me or Kim Keem
he's talked about me a few times in this
situation but this one
is special all right well here we go if
I talked about under members sorry that
girl came from some [ __ ] stupid
people
that was his job uh recently he's gotten
to a controversy ladies and gentlemen oh
I'm sorry like maybe 15 seconds yeah I
love what he thinks my job is heard on
the H3 podcast to stalk me
um because he's like he saw he wants to
like he wants to be us
I do I do he wants to okay Brantley I
love you you could never have a bad take
there's a limit to the jealousy argument
like there's got to be a limit to it you
can't you know what I mean
okay but we love Brantley shot us right
[Laughter]
this guy was hired on the H3 podcast to
stalk me that's awesome like that was
his job uh recently he's gotten to a
controversy you don't even make videos
he works full-time you know
it was a full-time job yeah I'm sorry he
works more than you so what's happening
ladies and gentlemen because he tried to
get somebody fired uh a security guard
in a Marriott and I know a lot of you
already know this story but we're going
to cover it again because there is an up
thing you already know this story like
he's talked about this honest show
before multiple times yeah but here's
the update the update is yeah just watch
I don't want him okay okay this is
awesome
day all right so he's walking through a
parking garage all right
all right
all right throws down his skateboard
he's gonna get on a skateboard people
can I just call sorry his his video is
format is [ __ ] awful why does the
whole screen occupied I'm disabled by
this giant disabled keemstar Banner it's
like the video itself is so small and
weird to look at I feel like I'm getting
a pop-up down here in our DiCaprio
doesn't it feel like that I feel like
I'm looking at spam like I want to close
it because I'm being like acoustic okay
anyway you already know this story but
we're going to cover it again because
there is an update all right so he's
walking through a parking garage all
right
throws down his skateboard he's gonna
get on a skateboard people now this is
the right color people
[Music]
looking at me skating he is skating
like 80 year old like a crosswalker
energy I don't even know how you could
say this and not be embarrassed I just
want to say a few things real quick like
I love them for this because what was a
bad memory they made so funny to me and
also I love that I was skating for such
a little amount of time so slow so slow
and he has to stop it and go he's
skating he's skating he's skating you're
literally you're probably going half a
mile per hour
you know what I mean
um by the way shout out to
Mary who says love if you're reading
this I want to pass the torture of
hairline
uh her
hierarchy to use the website
I can't afford to maintain the site oh
they own the domain they want to give it
to you yeah I think so I'll I'll take it
over okay
thank you Lex says Zach please do the
21-8 and raw sound bite for my sis it's
her 21st birthday
I'm 21. [ __ ] you there it is all right
let's continue
and here
and here comes keemstar's Superior
animal
the hero in this story yeah
garage Park exactly this guy is in
charge of the parking garage he's a
janitor
yeah you don't we actually don't need
any commentary Brantley does everything
for us all right let it play Hey
you're not supposed to do that
supposed to be wearing skateboards here
oh sorry about that
look at the size around here
see inside
why are you laughing bro
why are you laughing you just [ __ ] up
you broke the rules I mean I don't like
it but I would be laughing too because
the man is like screaming at him but
that's his job his job is to make sure
that that parking garage is safe
Brantley well yeah but he ain't got to
be like that I got you like did you hear
him rewind it you don't realize what I'm
saying he's the Off Script Brantley
she's like no did you know no but did
you watch that that was crazy are we
watching the same video
this is awesome
why would you even feign to be mad about
this it just makes you look like an
idiot punk ass kid look at this punk ass
kid skateboarding he's literally maybe
you're as far away he's gonna cause the
Marriott a lawsuit okay he's gonna cause
all kinds of lawsuits okay you're
tripping no I'm not tripping so you
think it's just he's just trying to get
to his his car if he saw a car backing
up I'm sure he'd stop no no no but
that's not the point my point is that
the dude is the security guard is just
being a dick about it like I don't see
no signs either to be honest but if
there is a son I feel like the dude
should be able to say it so we pause at
the wrong time because I want to see if
he says there is I disagree Brantley if
I am working that parking garage my job
is to make sure these punk ass kids
aren't skating and causing a lawsuit or
a loser that's your job you're a fun
sucker
and your car is on the other [ __ ] end
of the airport parking lot or whatever
yeah you gonna ride your damn skateboard
if I get yelled at I'm not gonna be a
[ __ ] okay but I would love what does
that mean
great question Dan asked me that
yesterday too yelled at you're not gonna
be a [ __ ] about it where what is your
what is what is your code exactly he's
like you're being so disrespectful
laughing in his face but then he's like
if somebody yelled at me like that I
[ __ ] I wouldn't be a [ __ ] I wouldn't
be a [ __ ] I went back down it's like
lightly comply immediately like what is
the right balance yeah you have no
anyway okay [ __ ] Brantley is slay as
[ __ ] that's why she's dressed as Nancy
Kerrigan
because she's a gold star winner
someone said Sleeper Agent Brantley yeah
she is totally
#free apprently free Brantley
sure farming
because he's being mean all right well
let's see let's see what happens here I
wanna yeah let me let me finish are you
encouraging him no no I'm not I'm just
I'm just hoping okay and don't ride your
skateboard offensive call security down
here you got it real funny huh
yet I'd be pissed off all right I'm just
trying to do my job screaming at him and
getting his
why the [ __ ] are you laughing at me bro
he's walking off he's going away why is
he getting in his face and jumping on
him because he's trying to leave he's
being a punk ass kid but he's oh you
[ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] period he's being a punk ass
kid he's being a [ __ ] ass dude he's
being a punk ass he's being a [ __ ] ass
grown man all right actually again you
were so polite I mean his art bro listen
came this is why you got you can't lie
you just gotta you know you're not angry
about this like just be honest bro you
don't have to feign
that you're out right because you look
like a [ __ ] yeah I can't you look so
stupid
like just be yourself man just be honest
it's way better content when you're just
yourself and you're honest you don't
have to lie to kick it bro
we're leaving right now sir I told you
have a good day have a good day period
bye
little man titties look at him laughing
he's still laughing I think she stands
UAB
I don't like AB but oh no you know what
I'm not gonna go no at the beginning she
goes he's in love with me but
wait she said that yeah yeah she said uh
he's obsessed with me
I've had no interaction with this girl
whatsoever what was I laughing is that
was that what I was laughing at no no it
was before it was right before that yeah
dumb [ __ ] a b
yeah this is awesome
I would too
the [ __ ] is so um
and now he's now he's gonna grab the
camera he's trying okay he's trying to
be
we're going
and now he's now he's playing the victim
okay going sir we're going playing
sorry for the shaky camera work I'm
holding my booster board shaking
we are walking being escorted to our car
yeah you are being excited you said that
was security that's a [ __ ] janitor
go
[Laughter]
see and this is what I meant at the
beginning of like there's like
Keem isn't even taking the stance of
like oh it was wrong to get this guy
fired it's just like you were rude to a
janitor and you skateboarded that's your
crime
it's like you know I I understand that
like the vibe today is just lying and
people buy it but like this is so
there's not there's not even a basis
like you can't even get the LIE out yeah
and that's what makes it so good is
because like Cameron his you know his
his goons they all like just make up
[ __ ] about your whoever and they just go
with everyone knows it's a lie even the
people who are fans know it's a lie and
no one has just common sense no one ever
just says the [ __ ] truth so not just
to see what happens when they have to
interact with the real world is just
awesome I think what their strategy is
they all know that they're feigning
outrage and I think the goal is to
convince people outside of their bubble
to get angry about it yeah they're
trying to damage you like they're not
trying to they actually want to dance
yeah yeah yeah so that I think that's
their goal but Brantley did not get the
memo
or is she just unwilling to make herself
look that dumb
like it's even if I want to play like
like if you were saying something like
that even wanna align with you I
wouldn't even know how to like how do I
lie about this it's so [ __ ]
ridiculous yeah yeah Brantley is she has
way too much Integrity yeah and Kim has
a lot of cognitive dissonance I would
say a lot of comment against dissonance
it's [ __ ] got him dude
I'm about to Tribute another picture you
want to get home but
his job is to make sure that people are
not his job is to clean the [ __ ]
trash and to make sure things are safe
right baby awesome while he was walking
in there I did not see a why would they
have no skates that doesn't make any
sense if I own the Marriott I want that
janitor to be working there because that
guy's doing his job he's making sure
some punk ass [ __ ] kids are going
around trying to get a lawsuit to sue my
[ __ ] company maybe I completely get
it but he did not need to talk to a
customer that way maybe the customer
didn't know he couldn't skateboard he
literally asked I didn't see him where
are they he didn't see the [ __ ]
skateboard signs also you dumbass you
have a six foot five dude you own that
four Arabs in a parking structure who
are recording you who the [ __ ] gonna
have a lawsuit you idiot like seriously
like he's coming at us chasing us who's
gonna cause the lawsuit right exactly
yeah
liability huge liability exactly
I love how he's trying to paint this
picture that you're like tearing it up
right you're like he's like two and a
half no loitering no loitering he thinks
I'm a lot cooler than what I am like he
thinks I'm just this young cool kid yeah
maybe he's 30. bro even when he was an
adult when he adult man he was talking
[ __ ] about me when the crater Clash was
coming around and he was on one of those
podcasts and someone said how old is he
and he's like oh 30 he's like if he's
30. he goes what the I thought he was a
lot younger than that he looks good for
his age game Star yeah well taking care
of yourself but listen here young man
you gotta listen to him listen to the
security guard also I will say keemstar
just as a note if you do date 18 year
olds you're gonna look older by
comparison yeah right it does create a
little bit of a contrast there it's just
it's just a shocking contrast
why is the [ __ ] janitor the dude that
cleans up after the customer what the
[ __ ] is he approaching him being a dick
and getting in his face while he's
trying to leave Bradley let me ask you a
question you're being humiliated right
now bro
wait can we see the live chat I gotta
see what people are saying I don't I
mean you look at it after the show yeah
bad okay which that was part of the
irony too is like because when Abe was
showing it to me yesterday I suppose I
was had the same thought I was like I
want to see how people are reacting this
a like half the audience was like
laughing because brantley's being pretty
funny here but then the other half
is oscillating between a b deserve to
get yelled at because he was being rude
to saying things like ALU Akbar a b and
like he's gonna and it's like again like
you were just describing the cognitive
dissonance of like I'm mad about this
because he was being so rude while
simultaneously just being like crazy
[ __ ] racist baby for no reason yeah
it's just wild dude it's like holy [ __ ]
do you have Brantley she needs to host
of the show Kim you need to take a step
back to the queen you need to Bow and
reverence
hey what in your [ __ ] that's so
[ __ ] up why in your brain would give
you the okay that it's okay to [ __ ]
skate car garage like what no I just got
back from that ain't no [ __ ] Escape
oh here we got a donut from caddy uh she
wow she's five bucks that's crazy I mean
if someone sat there videoing me it
might make me more irritated than usual
okay
great Insight from caddy that's someone
who donated on his stream anyway the
point is is that uh this is Brantley
should I watch more or is that kind of
the I think all the way up to the end
it's pretty good okay okay
I want a skateboard to my to my thing to
my cards right there if it's even right
there [ __ ] it it's right there but if
it's far away why not it'll be fun and
if I see a car I'm not a dumbass I'ma
see the cars there and I'ma stop
Brantley or get up to bed you have a
mental disability known as gen Z
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] wow Zinger dude also what the
[ __ ] was that that is the greatest part
about something this whole thing is that
sound box is that like his Rim shot yes
yeah
some things to just play that whenever
he thinks he really he really got one
over sometimes you gotta support
yourself you know yeah I've I'm I love
that I love that so much
so he's doing his own Rim shots
I said you go I set him up and I knock
them down
can I get a button like that we we must
yeah give you like goofy game show music
button that you can slam let me hear
that again I I need to I need to wow I'm
not a dumbass I'm gonna see the cars
there and I'ma stop Brantley or get out
of the way you have a mental disability
known as gen Z
first of all that sound is way too long
it's like too big well that that's clean
like no that's clean so it's great it's
just loud I'm just gonna pull that from
that clip and we'll have that because
yeah true right yeah you could just pull
it yeah I was thinking it should be
louder or more epic I'd be like Anna you
got a brain disease called gen Z
I'll just put some distortion on it and
just just deep fry the [ __ ] out of it
right yeah he also looks so proud to
afterwards can I put something out
because maybe you pointed out that he
has somewhat feminine mannerisms and
there's nothing wrong with that right no
not at all but watch how he pushes this
button and if I see a car I'm not a
dumbass I'ma see the cars there and I'ma
stop Brantley you have a mental
disability known as gen Z
[Music]
[Applause]
not that it needs explaining but they
don't know this but my skateboard also
has brakes with the boosted board I was
going two miles an hour but it has
brakes that's how when the guy walked up
I hit him a break immediately just put
your foot down at that speed yeah
but yeah
uh thank you by the way to Lex be
thumbing oh we already thanked you looks
thank you to
Elaine Christian 10 gifted subbies thank
you and Derek runs for 10 gifted subbies
thank you so much
we love you
just I love that doesn't have common
sense and I know one day and I know my
surroundings I know when to be aware
that makes me worst three all right okay
I'm just not dumb
he's old he can't ride a skateboard and
he can't he's
oh he got cataracts in his eyeballs so
he can't see nothing so he can't see if
there's a car coming if he did
skateboard so Bradley's heading on old
people how ironic and
again don't worry we gotta give it more
space
it was way too fast wait let's check the
mannerisms again how about so he can't
see nothing so he can't see if there's a
car coming if he did skateboard so
Bradley's heading up he's drunk by the
way I just realized yeah an old people
how ironic
I don't I love my nana she's old I love
her to death and I love my papa bro you
his pushes per minute are way off yeah
wanna know why because they're [ __ ]
cool and they would agree all right I I
get it it's enough
Brantley to Divine I bow to your
reverence you are awesome and yeah yeah
you should be thankful to have
such an incredible girlfriend as you
he's pathetic you can do better you can
do better but I get it in all
seriousness when I was watching this I
was like I was actually worried about
her I was like God help her I was glad
that the episode was at least 30 minutes
longer hopefully his boomerass might
have forgot but I felt like as soon as
the recording stopped he was gonna snap
you think so that's her out or something
I think she's
I I don't think so to be honest I don't
think she seems yes I get the dynamic oh
I I'm sure she could hold her own yeah
yeah but yeah he'll probably get mad at
her the next day or maybe when he's
sober he's drunk when he sees this
segment right now yeah really that's why
when we're live you've got to go with
the bed right I got a scent the sound do
you want to try something out with it
are you trying to make like a joke or
something
towards AB or
what he's asking you to set him up for
the sound but yeah if you could make
some sort of Slam on and so I said a b
where's your camel
oh that's pretty good that feels good
yeah come on let's go with Jimmy I need
my own button though we can set that up
we'll get that going and then I said
Zach what are you doing [ __ ] on a
toilet
[Music]
I like this do you feel that Jimmy's the
Jazz fingers
uh let's see Ian tell me what do you
think about Kanye West
[Music]
to find choreography for the beginning
you need a button and you need to be
able to push it like Keem like delicate
just Boop yeah think of like think of
like touching a toe like that just a
little okay yeah
I think that's a beautiful dance for it
walk it up and then and then hit it yeah
there you go it's a vibe
ah you know he's gonna react to this and
what can you even say bro
my favorite comment though my favorite
comments in the chatter wait who is this
right because it's a it's a b associate
producer on the History Podcast their
fans are like he's way he's so in the
weeds yeah yeah it's like I was making
fun of like Jamie from Joe Rogan or
something it's just yeah I'm just like
okay
yeah well congratulations keemstar on
your new show you see it's doing really
well
wow cam just said something for you and
not to view shame but it does have 18
000 views after two months and I mean
that's really good for some channels
right so I'm not going to view shame him
on that
look at that I just love this [ __ ]
sound oh that's the sap that's his true
self
Keen back to you that's how you hit the
button right there we love those oh my
God the wing on his eye is also Beauty
yes Kim's slide
all right thank you keemstar for the
laughs and Brantley the goddess uh we
love you
period
I love that
um
I guess we should get to the I gotta pee
though but we'll if when I come back
I'll be fast we'll get to the Logan
coffee Zilla thing which hap it started
over the break and it was so
good actually I don't think we ever
watched
Logan's original response to Coffee
which is in my opinion one of the
greatest response slash defense you
watch it on your member stream you
should yeah apology
uh videos ever I don't know if it's too
repetitive maybe you could do a poll see
if people want us to watch that or just
get straight to
um coffee's video right coffee
incorporates some of it in his videos
yeah I would say he said I'm not even
responding to it because he retracted it
but I don't have that Oh you mean the
original one yeah yeah yeah I'm not
retracting I didn't I don't give a
contract he actually published his uh
the original video he was going to make
before on his patreon
oh that would be good to watch the yeah
you want to do the poll I'll just go pee
you guys want me to watch Logan Paul's
original video where he attacks coffee
Zilla it's the worst video I've ever
seen uh it is insanely entertaining but
maybe it's old news and you all don't
care I'm gonna go to the bathroom
[Music]
so how's everyone doing today Dan has
burned together polls so I'm going to
talk hello I just cannot express how
much I I love that button yeah okay it
pulls up it's a good that's great
let's see all right bed pulled in
just kidding
that's pretty good today yeah pretty
straightforward it's never a bad pull
sometimes thank you for saying something
never a bad call what were you about to
say love oh not a fan no what were you
about to say yes I was gonna say
sometimes it's bad
[Music]
it's somewhere around the ballpark of
one
there you go but you know
you're doing a new show doing impossible
things here yeah
I'm still doing something so um okay
yeah anyone here from Arizona guys
I'm from Dearborn cheers guys Cheers
Cheers
what is that
hmm is that that like syrup soda you
drink yeah soft yeah
it's called sup I upgraded glass a
little bit yeah I can tell you still
drinking that fuel [ __ ] love
I'm not anymore dude that fuel food
I just eat fast food nowadays yeah
yeah same stuff
just solid they opened KFC in my city so
I've been slamming the KFC lately
Chad says it looks like you're drinking
out of a flower vase
yeah but I wish I was doing that before
but I actually bought a proper jog now
big jug nice you got some big jugs huh
you know Lena bought some uh water
bottles like I don't even know which not
water bottles but like to drink her
water these cups that are that big and
we have a small studio and Lena for some
reason insists on buying massive things
yeah it's starting to become a problem
but I don't want to say anything about
it like are you talking about like the
leader of water yeah but she doesn't
just get one she gets three of them she
gets a three pack and like our cabinet's
already stuffed but I don't want to
dictate what she buys so I just smile
and say oh yeah nice do you got like a
like open top fridge where you could
store it or not really it doesn't fit in
anything I don't know where she's gonna
put
interesting yeah sounds like a dilemma
I'm happy for her though
you gotta drink you know yeah
we're storing all those Legos by the way
I'm out of room homie that's actually
Instagram yes like on on the kitchen
counters just a bunch it's just a
flooding out dude I I need to wait this
pull is so bad oh [ __ ]
legitimately you go do you want to watch
Logan Paul's why does it matter if
they've seen it or not like why I don't
know why did you tack that on to the yes
because that's literally the options
that you said verbatim no do they want
to watch it yes or no why you got to put
words in their mouth you because they
put the words they're going to say yes
the words that are listed here are the
words that came out of your mouth what
are they if they if somebody says
because if I don't do exactly what you
say you always say it's a bad pull so I
literally okay well you have yourself to
thank for that say that Dan you sound
like a punk ass kid right now I did not
say that I did not tell you to write
that okay well half the audience doesn't
want to watch it so I'd say uh we should
probably just move on forget it thank
you
Bella Simmons says quick shout out to
all the crew who kept us entertained
over the break baby Arena Ian love
and Ethan thank you guys
thank you Bella there it is thank you
all right well we're not gonna watch
that but what we will watch let's watch
okay do another poll that Dan
do you guys what would you like the pole
to be Ethan should we watch coffee
zillas
new video
by the way the PO somebody not me put up
a poll asking if that was a bad poll and
the no is winning by a lot so
congrats you made a great point I did
not tell you to write that where's that
coming from
you said no the bad pull on me all right
what's the new poll where what are we
pulling now
do you want to watch the new coffee
villa video
yes or no do you want to walk why are
you guys fighting me Dan
Zilla video yes no
maybe so three two eight pulled up
all right
yeah Dan you called that poll so fast
bro
well you can only have one pole at a
time so I had to close it to make yours
okay so it looks like we got some uh
enthusiasm for this one here
to those who voted no
um it's you'll enjoy it stop it
just skip forward
uh let's see
[Music]
foreign
here it is
yeah so Logan made a video after you got
absolutely bought like bought deed for
his response where he was like I'm gonna
sue you this is [ __ ] you're defaming
me oh you played a vid an audio that was
recorded without my manager's consent
you're a criminal and you're going to
get like crazy [ __ ]
and so he made a video being like I'm
sorry I'm going to give 1.3 million
dollars and thank you and then she
starts thinking thank you coffeezilla
thank you
thank you for humbling me thank you bro
so anyway here's here's coffee's
response which is really good
coffee Zilla everybody
1.2 million views in six hours okay King
Jesus
she did Logan has taken
a beating lately
finally over Logan Paul apologized
coffeezilla your slime is he is a
lopsided journalist with an agenda more
like an internet criminal oops wrong
video that was the first response he
actually apologized in another response
knowing that he bothers me the
defamation lawsuit that is what happened
because this is wrong this is wrong hold
on wait a second that's not it either uh
turns out it's actually on his secondary
Channel that's why I couldn't find it
it's entitled thank you coffeezilla it's
the third response from Logan you gotta
love that dude this guy you're such a
slime ball dude who's gonna believe that
he goes he went on a hole like [ __ ]
coffee Zilla tour and then he's like no
no thank you
you know what thank you bro he had a
severe laugh thank you thank you
and now now I just appreciate you so
much buddy thank you
we are coffeezilla we are gay anyway
Paul and it's a pretty big change in
Logan's attitude so far so let's see
what he has to say to us coffee Zilla is
not a criminal oh that's a relief I
thought Logan was going to hire me but
an awesome Christmas
[Music]
yeah that's a good one right there boy
does have some major admissions in it I
want to go through for one Logan
apologizes to me I called him I
apologized my initial response to his
series was that of of a fire uh an ego
not only that Logan also pledges a one
doesn't show but in Logan's video he
goes listen I'm a fighter at heart yeah
I was like shut the [ __ ] up dude you're
a fighter at heart so he's trying to
he's trying to turn into like look it's
just admirable to me to want to fight
everything I'm just a cool dude
0.3 million dollar refund plan for
people who bought his nfts I am
personally committing a thousand each to
this which is about 1.3 million dollars
in addition to that he also promises to
finish crypto Zoo which was left
abandoned and then step three obviously
finish and deliver the game as outlined
in the white paper now I'll be honest
this is a big change in tone and
honestly a lot of this is good news it's
great that victims are going to get
something back Logan seems to
acknowledge his continuous lapse in
judgment he's not suing me which is also
cool and frankly this new response is
just uh way better than his last two I
think we can all acknowledge that while
also acknowledging that it's not really
a perfect response either there are
still major problems here like for
example many of the victims just have
been ignored in this response a lot of
accusations I really want to know what
Brantley thinks about this
I'm still thinking about how smart and
cool it was yeah
uh I wonder if she would be interested
in moving to LA and joining our crew
after they break up probably
awesome
Brantley if you need an escape you
message us you email us
um we need some slick
perspectives unrelated important update
Lena is At Doe bricks right now oh my
God what's happening oh it's happening
oh my God so she's getting a full pie so
we can all try it I I don't know Sam was
telling us something about how many you
could buy wait they I thought they
lifted the limit because oh did they I
don't know yeah it's a limit dude last
time I heard somebody was there they
said it was kind of deserted
I'm not sure
I'm texting right now yeah
should we just get what's the best way
to test it just cheese slices
or should we get like [ __ ] on it
probably cheese
the honey pepperoni I'm not interested
in that
it's fun
but don't you think if you want to if
you want to rate it it's got to be
cheese
like a control you know what is control
group control group what is fousey
cheese wants although fousey would
probably be in favor of the maple syrup
on it right let's get a cheese a large
cheese our extra large cheese whatever
is their largest size so everyone can
participate
to have gone unanswered and worse Logan
still seems to be playing the victim a
lot so in this video I'm gonna do my
best to give Logan credit where credit
is absolutely due while also sharing
moments where I think this apology fell
flat and let me start with a positive
for example I think if you're an
outsider who is not affected by this
scam and you wanted a reason to love
Logan Paul again I think this Nails it I
mean he's giving back some of the money
he's apologizing so if you're a
card-carrying member of the low gang you
can rest easy here Logan says he's sorry
he says he's making things right and I
think that's the point of this video is
to speak to his core audience to tell
them he didn't scam anyone and for what
it's worth I think Logan succeeds here
the problem is I don't think I or the
crypto Zoo holders were who Logan was
really addressing here and this is where
the response Falls more flat because he
doesn't adequately address the real
victims of crypto Zoo which I I think
they're rightfully angry about and I
want in his original video he's like by
the way and this dude who lost 150 000
what kind of idiot lets his kid buy Zoo
it's like uh
what
yeah he was trying to he was trying to
assassinate the character of some of the
people that lost their ass he goes this
guy did a rug call before he believed me
what a [ __ ] is still his money [ __ ] face
I have to spend some time talking about
that because again they've been the
heartbeat of this whole story and they
feel very differently about this
response than Logan's core audience does
they don't feel like it's enough and I
want to talk about why starting with the
1.3 million dollars repayment plan
because obviously this is the strongest
part of Logan's entire response actually
opening up his wallet and I don't want
to minimize that in this video I just do
want to put it in context because 1.3
million dollars is a lot of money
unfortunately the scam was much bigger
than 1.3 million dollars so the fact is
most victims are not going to be made
whole by this plan just in zoo coins
alone blockchain evidence shows 7.7
million dollars was stolen by dude these
two [ __ ] goons man that he hired to
do this whole thing
1.3 million dollars
yeah I heard he's done I heard he's
donating a million dollars to the
Habitat for Humanity right
by Logan's team depending on who you
believe and this refund does nothing for
those victims it doesn't even apply to
the holder of zoo coins at all you get
nothing if you bought this in-game
currency this refund only applies to
current egg holders so they can cash out
that nft for the initial mint price in
crypto which matters sort of because
crypto has crashed a lot so even though
people spent 2.5 million dollars on
these eggs in order to refund all these
holders at mint price it now only costs
1.3 million dollars in today's money
which again is nice but doesn't do
enough because the zoo coins were most
of this scam I mean that's where most of
the money was spent wasn't just on the
nfts it was on this in-game currency
which Logan seems to have no intention
of refunding and his response for why is
pretty bad he responds to somebody who
lost eighty thousand dollars who told
him I hope this isn't just doing what
you have to do technically to not get
sued Logan replies when with a
screenshot of his white paper and laid
Yeah so Logan apparently is in his
Discord arguing with people
and uh this is my favorite part this is
my favorite part because
Logan really
really shows
he breaks the facade because obviously
he [ __ ] hates coffee Zilla and you
know what I mean his original video is
how he feels yeah
and he gets he starts arguing with
people in Discord who he scammed
or someone only someone yeah
uh he's Peter explains to another member
of the Discord I believe there has been
a misconception here as outlined in the
white paper zoo was created to support
cryptozu and was not intended to be an
investment vehicle when you sold or
bought is not my decision and look dude
acting like it's the stock market like
hey bad time to sell
not my fault
nah dude to be fair to him there was a
misconception that zoo was an investment
vehicle but it's a misconception that he
created I mean he's the one who said
kryptos it was a fun game that earned
you money and how it earned you that
money was that your nfts earned you Zoo
tokens you know things that were
supposed to have value that was the
whole point of the game so to suggest
that these coins weren't advertised as
valuable or an investment vehicle is
insane especially since Logan's own team
had rules for selling based strictly on
the value of said investment vehicle
quote rules for selling no selling until
a 200 million dollar market cap so I
think it's fair to say if Logan's own
yeah this is the part that he never uh
acknowledges which is that
he keeps saying he wasn't scamming but
he had an arrangement with these three
guys behind the scenes to buy the tokens
before they went public so that they
could sell them at a super high price
that's insider trading and I'm pretty
sure that's illegal
uh so
he literally just got scammed before he
could scam the team we're buying Zoo
coins early waiting for them to go up in
value to a certain level and then
selling them that sounds like an
investment vehicle albeit a very stupid
one so this explanation definitely
doesn't hold water and Logan obviously
just doesn't want to be on the hook for
Zoo coins instead he just kind of wants
to refund the much smaller part of the
nfts what makes this even worse is that
this refund doesn't even apply to
everyone who bought these nfts uh you
know what I just want to watch the
police part this is my favorite which is
a large percentage of the actual victims
and this is pretty bad this was brought
to Logan's attention by one of the
people in the Discord joao says quote
Logan Paul what will happen to the
people who sold everything at a loss
when the project appeared to be quote
abandoned will everyone who minted be
able to get that refund or just the
current owners now in reply to this
someone in the Discord said if you sell
you lose common investing knowledge dude
I love that they're calling is investing
when you sell you lose
there's no
it's all gone the money is gone like
if you hold you're an idiot
this is by the way Logan Paul's all
King Vincent
and Logan replies seeming to agree with
this idea which is just kind of a
terrible perspective for Logan to have
when he seems to be saying that he wants
to refund these people and he's the
reason a lot of these people left and
this is where Logan's new apology starts
to ring more Hollow it's in all of the
follow-ups after the response video
because I don't know if he can help
himself from betraying how he really
feels about this because in another
Discord exchange Logan says please do
not put any more money into cryptozoo
which by the way is quite reasonable to
say but then somebody follows up and
says guys can someone explain what he
said with not investing but rather than
replying oh guys I just meant like I
don't want anyone else losing money or
you know I don't want anyone else
recklessly gambling Logan replies
instead quote I will no longer be the
scapegoat for anyone's financial
decisions again it's so good right it's
crazy
he's on Discord and he so he sees
himself as the scapegoat once again it's
time to get a it's time to get PR dude
we are he just can't help himself
there's no way after the dead body
Fiasco that he was isn't hooked up with
like Crisis managers PR he's got it all
he's with the WWE now whatever f e what
are we calling it now so I'm kind of is
there an FM or the same well it was WWF
there's no it doesn't mean WWF in a long
WWE now yeah so wait what's the E stand
for energy entertainment yeah World
Wrestling why'd they drop the F because
they got sued by World Wildlife
Foundation what yeah
those people are
they're saving the panty slammed hey
they need to get choke slammed dude off
the cage at Hell in the zone you taking
WWF from us you [ __ ] Wildlife freaks
Chad said his PR is all criminals too
yeah yeah exactly here I think I have a
picture of his PR guy uh oh yeah I have
a picture of his guy who does crisis
management hold on let me pull it up
um here let me pull this up it's crazy
2023 23 we're still talking about Logan
doing this kind of stuff yeah I got a
picture of his PR guy uh here he is
ah it's so stupid sorry that was
definitely a funnier joke in there but I
thought you were pulling up PMP
no let's go that's who he needs if PVP
is involved this none of this would have
ever happened true thank you thank you
which is a wild response for someone
who's claiming to refund people because
it implies that he thinks he's the
victim here and this is just insane to
say as the face of this project which
got everyone involved because I think it
betrays how he feels about this
situation he doesn't seem to see
anything wrong with advertising a game
that will make you money it never
delivering millions of dollars being
stolen by criminals he hired and then
when all of those people want their
money back he feels like he's the
scapegoat like oh these guys shouldn't
have believed me when I advertise to
them a fun game that will make you money
it just doesn't make any sense I mean
Logan had a simple job to do all he had
to do was just come out apologize get as
much money back for the victims as
possible but he himself can't help but
play the victim here in fact I have a
third example of how Logan might really
feel because Logan tweeted right before
this response he says quote The Matrix
is real praying you'll never become one
of them and by the way one of the
greatest Tweets in Twitter history
unbelievable this man is being like
canceled as hard as suicide forest and
he's dropping Matrix tweets I guess
that's what you're I guess that's what
I'm a [ __ ] Bluebird I guess
that's what happens to your brain he was
you know what's funny he was trying to
get allies like Andrew Tate and then
Andrew says like nah [ __ ] you I hate you
too mucho broken though
now I guess he's trying to channel
Andrew Tate here unsuccessfully
basically saying like ah I'm getting
attacked not because I did anything
wrong or scammed anyone I'm just I'm
just too much of a truth teller I'm just
an enemy of the system that's why I must
be getting attacked but if that's the
case we didn't have to wonder did The
Matrix force you to apologize did it
force you to hand back 1.3 million I
just think comments like this go so far
to undercut his apology because it's
very clear that instead of actually like
caring about the victims he feels like
he's a victim I mean he's saying like oh
pray you never become its Target
here's Andrew tape uh from January 11th
though even in Romanian prisons they
talk about Logan Paul being a scammer
that's so awesome I mean listen I never
said he's not funny right I never said
he's not funny doing good
this guy tweets a lot for someone who's
in prison I mean I guess it's not crazy
to think he has a phone in there
he's just really he's has somebody on
the outside who's tweeting for him Aiden
yeah Aiden's got his login
[ __ ] dude oh wait this one
I've had I just filled in my visit oh
this is the Ada Ross one
where's your girl
[Laughter]
oh no he's pumping uh Bradley
the easiest way to love yourself as a
man is to be proud of yourself okay
interesting oh that's good advice
young men should listen to them take the
easy way out that's not strong advice no
matter what yep
don't self-reflect never
no it's self-reflection is that's some
beta [ __ ] that's beyond beta that's like
Delta that's Delta [ __ ] it's the most
important thing and being able to give
love and share love like what else are
we doing all this [ __ ] for completely
and you can't pour from an empty cop and
before you give love to anybody else you
have to truly love yourself and I think
the easiest way to love yourself as a
man is to be proud of yourself and to be
proud of yourself to decide who you want
to be that's such a weird simplistic
take yeah I mean this is just beatbox
[ __ ] standard self-help [ __ ] but what
does that even mean be proud the best
way you can love yourself which by the
way is like a life like anyone who tells
you that that's something that you can
just do is [ __ ] lying to you for
money that's like a lifelong journey
right of of
self-discovery and acceptance and here
he's like nah just be proud of yourself
yeah how is that deep how has that help
anybody it's not it's a bunch of
platitude [ __ ] or the inside of it
just convert and start over you know or
yeah
the metaverse inside of The Matrix
try your best to achieve it why do you
think people struggle with being proud
of themselves I think because they know
they're failing I think that most people
failing in life know very well they're
failing and it doesn't matter what
Avatar you decide to by the way in
prison does is he failing or winning
right now
do you think he thinks he's winning or
failing as he sits in prison right now
is he proud
I think he thinks this is the
destination I mean this is the destiny
of the chosen one he's Neo and he's
being held by the matrix
it's more than that he's he's Christ
he's Christ waiting I don't remember the
scene where Neo sat uh
sat without any motion for like a month
for uh our wording somebody I missed
that scene did you watch the new one
maybe he was in the sequel maybe that
was in the fourth one in the new one by
the way I did that movie is [ __ ]
horrible man that was so disappointed
how you all gonna re-boot for that [ __ ]
that movie sucked it's a bummer to
absorb who you decide to be you can
decide Kyle who was that got up or was
that that had to be stymy and it doesn't
matter what Avatar you decide to absorb
or who you decide to be who is that
E I think Kyle yes Kyle
yo this is boring guess the arm of the
nelk guy who designed this house your
aunt
steiny I'm sorry but right the curtains
the the curtains are a little dated
there Kyle they look like elongated
cheap curtains
I've only seen those in my grandma's
house exactly
you can decide to be it and you know
true in your heart if you're giving 100
of your energy towards becoming oh this
might actually be when they went to meet
him and uh
I think so Dubai or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah it doesn't matter if you want to
become a famous musician doesn't matter
it doesn't matter don't come become a
pro fighter doesn't matter what you want
to be those are the only paths in life
and I'm gonna go these are all the only
approved paths in life it'll come become
a pro fighter no matter what you want to
be oh wait should I didn't go back far
enough if your energy towards becoming
or not it doesn't matter if you want to
become a famous musician just a musician
I'm going to come a bodybuilder doesn't
matter bodybuilder right become a pro
fighter Chrome fighter doesn't matter
what you want to be those are the only
things he can conceive of it's awesome
Which Way Western man
big strong
you know in your heart if you're
actually trying or not you have to
decide what you want to be
and you do that
oh [ __ ] bro no shot even they literally
said No at the same time was that an
accident or is that they said No at the
same time
okay it's the Matrix man this is the
Matrix dude that was crazy wait hit me
with it again ready no you know when
your heart is let's try it again because
you hit that perfectly doesn't matter
what you want to be you know in your
heart you're actually trying or not you
have to decide what you want to be and
try and become it and a lot of the
people who are genuinely happy life in
our hearts no they're not trying that
hard self-love is the most important
that's just not even that interesting
though to be honest with you
there it is Wadley Wharton that's the
game that's the game
yeah we get it Logan Paul's a piece of
[ __ ]
small dick energy
and he has small dick energy
Sarah said I bought dobrex this past
weekend it was 80 bucks for two pizzas
that's really expensive yeah
Jesus bro
um here is a clip of oh no oh see this
is what Bradley gets and when he tries
to be real
here is oh [ __ ] that's crazy
yo he put that dead body there for him
to find
oh you think God rug pulled or the
architect rug pulled I rug pulled them
to get him in trouble
so here is Steve will do it who in fact
did jerk off his dog on take uh in
Bradley's words
um
dripping on Martin four he's still got
no kids yeah thank you you're [ __ ]
you're failing it like this music might
get us clamped
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah thank
you
yeah he goes you're failing in life I
was like bro at your drinking rate Steve
you're probably gonna be sterile
thank you like you're definitely
shooting blanks with the amount of
alcohol you consume bro
blanks
yeah so what I was wanting to wonder
about is
if Logan's uh stats are suffering what's
going on with Logan Paul
since all this happened because there
did seem to be a pretty big wave of
of people
um
turning against him right
and I mean these are his fans he ripped
off so
what are we really talking about here
where's this podcast oh here
impulsive one day ago
yeah he was pulling like really good
views I mean okay Andrew Santino 800 000
that's good
young gravy
I mean I guess it's not affected if this
still has 800 000 right
yeah I mean I'm not
too surprised
let's read the comments here on YouTube
if you're still if you're still in on
Logan
in 2023
you're in for life you know what I mean
like if you've gone if you've gone
through all the [ __ ] over the years
and and you're still a Logan Stan
okay anything anything short of him
murdering someone is bro come on we
don't you never know what really
happened yeah
here I'm going to download it at no
offense Logan but I just do the reason I
do that is let's check the like dislike
um
this is his most recent episode this
just came out yesterday so he's posted
already one episode this is two episodes
away the top comment is can't wait to
see Logan in court
okay not a great not a great start to
the comment section
uh everything else seems to be uh yeah
the dislikes are still quite bad show me
that show me that
right here
oh my gosh predominant yeah more more
dislikely so there's so there is there
is something going on here
8.7 K likes to 11k dislikes for audio
listeners oh thank you thank you wow AV
wow you love AB loves the audio
listeners doesn't he folks somebody
asked you
thank you guys thank you
here's a pro Logan comment it's crazy
how Mike railroads Logan in every
episode Logan barely gets a word in
well that's probably better for the show
oh there's only one hate comment how's
the lawsuit going
that's kind of a sarcastic comment I
assume yeah they must be cleaning it out
though with that dislike ratio
here here I have an idea you can go sort
by new and see what's
what's cooking fraudulent give the money
back
Prime is the most disgusting drink I've
ever had I agree with that I'm in the
minority though
Logan Paul's the huge joke wow it's like
a hundred percent bad in the new imagine
being a fan of Logan how much of a
douche do you have to be
Red Bull is better
I'll tell you about banana I've noticed
over the last year or two I think
YouTube has
um enhanced their comment section
algorithms significantly
um with probably their like AI chat
learning and everything to Mike Tyson
filter negative comments much more
aggressively it has to be really
overwhelmingly negative for all the
comments to to be bad and by the way
that's a good thing yeah on the whole I
think it is a good thing nobody needs
their comments section being full of
people like telling you to kill yourself
right right you know I mean it doesn't
help anyone yeah
Amy David says Abe cares about the audio
and has amazing hair there it is
old thank you thank you for that all
right do we we got a backup okay good so
here is Steve will do it and this was
what happened right when you ride for
the truth amongst the milk boys moment
right now I couldn't imagine being 34
and I have no kids especially when
you've been successful for so long like
yeah yeah get your [ __ ] together yeah
like you should have been having kids
since you like since you're like 26 28.
yeah you've been doing the internet for
so long and it's like well I was in a
relationship then that I thought was
going to work out that didn't work out
either it was that was an eight-year
relationship that's what I was saying we
gotta drink a lot right now drink a lot
and just get kind of what is this guy
has a one solution to every problem you
know what I mean
love that for him kind of sloppy and
we'll call all your exes and just see
which one's down to like get like
[ __ ]
you can do that sober
you know the alcoholics always like you
know it'd be fun if we did this drunk
let's go to the movie trunk
let's go what's wrong yeah let's go
watch the game drunk
I'm drunk
drunk driving a drunk Ninja
drunk ninja oh is that ninja oh that's
not the solution yeah that's what we
should do we usually get drunk and then
call every single X and just see which
one's down to get babies right inside
they get baby batteries disgusting bro
the [ __ ]
uh
uh they wonder why they have 98 men
the silver bold thing bro
yeah nice baby about it right inside the
cook up a Baby Dude wait is this the
right time stamp Olivia yeah he's just
like ragging on him for not having the
cold and not having kids is it behind us
or ahead of us where he's being like a
total dick
I think he's being a total dick through
all of it
must be only those because he's always
joking though he's like I'm gonna do it
by 26. like I'm gonna be married I'm
gonna have a baby no they're the clip
that I saw that has copyrighted music
was like a sustained and Superman yeah
it's edited together because they're
never really developing the other 10
things that you know you also need to
develop yeah that's why that's how I
found myself in the position because I I
was so this is raw talk
raw talk this is raw yeah that's just
straight from there you're watching it
raw baby focus on those other things
that I was like good at and I just focus
on more of the things that I was good at
and I got really far in my life like we
see on you know
everything outside of business you know
and I and it's hurt me it's hurt me in
tons of ways man like [ __ ] yeah you're
34 33 but yeah and you still got no kids
yeah
thank you that's that's like [ __ ]
started okay whatever because I guess
it's hard when it's not all edited
together
I do think I I but dude I got this man I
got this figured out I know what to do
now at least you have the whole being
super healthy and like it doesn't look
like he's being that mean when I watch
it yeah it's just clearly mess with this
yeah I don't know the way they edit it
together Brad yeah
it said you're failing in life you're
not married why don't you have kids yet
that's what happens we still love Steve
we just love Steve it's like when people
make the edits of you the alpha edits
you better watch it elf wait do we love
Steve because apparently he had a
falling out with Bradley and obviously
I'm more based on what though well based
on this opening no no no that was old
based on his tweet of like yo yeah yeah
yeah still that's just him talking to
his friend just joking around I think
but I'm saying in the divorce are you
with Mom or Dad I'm with Dad Bradley I
mean Bradley's Dad okay but Steve is a
cool dad so he's a cool dad will jerk me
off I'm the cool dad now which let's
dude is something weird in the
thumbnails like way too much like
contrast or something like their skin
looks all [ __ ] grainy Donnie
you see that
yeah but I've kind of been probably
sharpened a little bit more often I
think it's uh intended I think it's
meant to draw more attention but
some more creators do it
there it is Logan Paul there it is folks
still a douche ladies and gentlemen and
we'd love that for him
yeah oh you know what was funny maybe
this would be fun to look at
the day after this all he posted his uh
video [ __ ] on coffee Zilla he posted
this ad for prime
it's the worst timing ever and I'm not
even gonna lie oh comments are off so
Fun's over but let's let's see the like
dislike on this one dude okay
and let me just and again sorry to
dislike I'm just trying to get in while
I can
of course
it's an app for Prime Logan Paul KSI
surprise fan
I was feeling bad for KSI I was like
damn
wait we must have already looked at this
because oh we're on the same account
that's why it's already disliked ooh
yeah 177 000 dislikes to 83k yeah I mean
obviously he's getting ragged on by a
lot of the internet right now well there
it is Logan Paul good luck to you
um you know probably stay out of the
crypto space for a while
I'm sure another space that's right for
exploitation will come up soon
wake the [ __ ] up
so I'm sure soon there'll be like uh
dude he's looking he was on Pokemon
cards he made a bunch of money doing
that right
then he went to the crypto which he
still made a ton of money I don't know
how y'all [ __ ] buying this [ __ ] the
99 Originals I watched that with pure
and utter
shock but crypto [ __ ] next up it's gonna
be like um
well we don't know what's the next the
next wave to ride you know what's on the
come up right now time to invest
something really dumb I'm sure of it
so there's that uh yada yada okay
there is a tick tocker I wanted to show
you guys
this [ __ ] I didn't know how to feel
about it because it's so crazy
but it's also super entertaining but
it's [ __ ] up what he's doing
you guys tell me what you think I'm very
conflicted on this this guy you know the
copy he's the weirdest dude alive he's
doing [ __ ] first of all he's doing
shtick I understand that but his
tolerance for
humiliating himself or putting himself
in the most uncomfortable position ever
this man is is the weirdest man alive so
he just goes up to people and starts
[ __ ] with them and here's an example
cops have been called they are on their
way
for what
they're all on their way to pick you up
are you joking no
I'm serious
they are on their way I know you
and it's like scary right he seems like
a big guy too but he's like I would just
be honest with them when they get here
he's Relentless okay who are you just to
save you some trouble just be honest who
are you I'm Brent what Bren Bren yeah I
never heard it I never heard well that's
fine I'm just giving you a warning
they're on their way
okay
so what did I do I would just stick
around what did I do
you think I'm stupid
[Music]
do you think I'm stupid no no I just
said
he's like he's kind of Psych like he's
really I feel bad for this guy right as
I said everybody does
but it's it is funny
uh I don't know are you right he's my
favorite account you like this guy I
like him too oh yeah oh you're watching
him for years too
pranks
info brand this dude is one of the OG
YouTube pranksters I think are pretty OG
he has a 1.2 million followers dude he's
insane
he's F he makes me uncomfortable
watching
I love it I'm not stupid
I'm smart
okay
I just came to get this
I'm just letting you know they're on
their way you're scaring me okay
I I don't know who you are
by the way so so when this guy says
you're scaring me it's like
you gotta are you a normal person would
lay off but we're only halfway through
this video
oh he's wearing camera glasses in this
one
so so they just think he's a total
psycho he's not even holding a phone
that's why it looks a little grainy
yo this is I mean okay turn around that
happened just now in the vid you like
that tries to get away it's beautiful
let's see no they're on their way you're
just scaring me okay okay I I don't know
who you are you don't remember me I
don't remember you
I don't remember you
it's bread buddy
[Applause]
had you pulled up Bren bread yeah uh
bever don't die five five huh
I had you fooled
what's this thing where he's custom cans
of weird [ __ ] he drinks tuna juice
dolphin milk and he has actually a can
of it that it cracks open and drinks it
is terrifying you guys are right it's
both it is terrifying but like
it's compelling isn't that weird I mean
this guy is like um the cringe God you
guys all remember the cringe God but
like more K he's more capable you know
obviously
does he always hit them with I called
the police or does he no no it's
different every time all right all right
yeah this one is specifically is a
little bit like on the edge obviously
he's very he's clearly scared
they're all over in my opinion they're
all over the line
but here but he did meet up with this
guy later and
I saw there was a little bit context
yeah there was some kind of uh reuniting
because this video went like super viral
that's 1.7 million likes so it got like
I don't know 20 million views or some
[ __ ]
it's made for pitches but humans could
drink it too
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
the delivery is like so creepy like he
has this character down I love the just
the uncomfortable element to it like how
he can just be so comfortable with being
uncomfortable
yeah it keeps you on the edge of your
seat
I agree
bro I don't know of course yeah yeah
co-worker right brand new from
dealership you were always such a
nefarious Little Critter
LLC yes Kenneth would say remember this
I'll get a skedaddle man I'm gonna get
the hell out of here yeah it's nice to
see you too man
of course I I think I just yeah I think
I'm gonna go to hell of course yeah yeah
good guy good guy all righty I could
stare into those tears fears for hours
let me tell you
then how do you even process that if
you're that guy once he leaves but dude
oh my God it's so [ __ ] crazy he stuck
around for a while
yeah I see you guys hate it but I'm not
saying you need to like it right I'm all
I'm very conflicted on this like I agree
with y'all this shit's crazy
here there's some in here there
he goes up to someone who just got in a
car crash and he starts heckling the
dude it is so crazy and the cops there
he just cruises onto a [ __ ] dude
that's the first one I saw of his and I
was like what in the [ __ ] wait you found
that already
love and I were talking about it before
the show oh [ __ ]
this is one of the craziest videos I
ever saw I saw this and I immediately
have not looked back by a wenis am I
really seeing this
[Laughter]
what the hell happened
yeah so give me the rundown
we're in a little fender bender yeah
well it is the Walmart parking lot
a lot of things can happen yeah
how are your nerves
okay man they're all right yeah yeah
you always wear a flirty little Funyun
yeah of course Kenneth would say flf
remember this
[Laughter]
that's bread
bread bread
so flirty so little
such a Funyun huh I have no idea
remember this no really
okay check this out
just imagine you're a [ __ ] car crash
the police are there that's this
absolute [ __ ] psychopath I would
think that I I died and I'm in hell
right now yeah you're having brain
damage hallucinations now he's busting
out dolphin milk I mean how do you even
process this this is Joker Brian share
right here oh yeah he actually those are
like things he put over other cups so he
sells like just a bunch of those so you
can get you know you can buy it yeah
you want to taste and dolphin milk
yeah
I know you Ultra filter dolphin milk
yeah
milked dolphin on porpoise
dude I don't know who you are man he'll
calm the nerves
he won me over right now sweet
I sing
it's a [ __ ] cop there dude
it's so crazy Jesus Christ like it's
it's a bad trip it totally is he's the
DMT fairy that's what he said
My Father's Day
from every Mountainside
he's just not leaving
hell of a fender bender
oh I love this guy
har yeah
just observing
I like the work you do
kie
bye bye
okay take care
you keep keeping on
dude it's nuts like I'm sorry like a Jim
Carrey character oh my God it's so
[ __ ] up
I mean he I will be people shout is
hating a lot but he does pick his
victims pretty pretty well because he
never does it to women for example which
I guess it's something
that can't be true he's never done it to
a woman
yeah no that cannot be true no I'm not
one really yeah okay older men so
usually here he does it to a big guy he
goes up to a big guy so it's like he's
not picking on like little dudes and
it's physically intimidating them or I
mean he does but like let's see this
here's a big guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah
you it bugged it bugged out and flipped
to some other video what
okay here it is
again
pretty big boy
[Music]
still a kid at heart yeah
how you doing I'm drawing a blank right
now it's bread oh yeah we're doing good
how are you doing I'm doing good yeah
dolphin died five five
oh my goodness it's been a long time it
has been a long time a real long time
I'm doing swell you're looking good yeah
thank you yeah you're looking real good
yeah
they're real good
okay
[Laughter]
and that's what I a part of what I find
interesting let's do a poll is this
funny
horrible
or it is both an option
you know what I mean because it is both
but maybe
gray area okay for now
[ __ ]
okay getting weird and wild with Kenneth
and the boys you know
real weird
is that working yeah yeah you've been
drinking your milk I can tell yeah
you're really sprouted yeah yeah you did
I
was thinking about you a lot
this is It's Dawning on him that he has
no idea who this guy is and it's just
how dude I think
this is like my nightmare having an
interaction like this this is this I
mean this is yeah the word I hate having
normal interaction so this is yeah
imagine going through this yeah
there he has done it to women I'm seeing
FYI
people are saying this is a woman every
day
really I I'm scrolling through I didn't
find one maybe I'm wrong yeah it's
predominantly men but I have seen four
or five women so far
I guess anyway it's kind of
couldn't stop thinking about you you
know yeah because that would be the deal
I wrote a lot of passages in my journal
about it
yeah my therapist said you know if you
don't run out of them again and this is
where he goes crazy he makes him fear
fear
like this dude has a journal and he's
writing about me
[ __ ] dude you feel like you're in a
horror movie
but yeah here we are laughing
just
try to make some sort of doll that looks
like him and use that as a cuddle buddy
and so that's what I did
yeah I did
but
here we are
the real thing
In the Flesh yeah
dude
are you speaking of milk
remember this sir
dolphin milk
[Laughter]
do you want to sit no are you sure yeah
[Music]
all right buddy
good to see you as well I'm gonna
skedaddle yeah don't die 5'5
[Music]
all right pretty wild [ __ ] I just want
to get checked the pulse of America
on this one it's pretty uh split dead
even here although if you look at if you
combine the funny and both then you
getting a pretty favorable Outlook it's
50 50. that'd be well you could look
either way really either 75 percent of
people find it funny or 75 75 of people
find it horrible
both are true 50 50. that's what's so
[ __ ] weird about this guy's content
here you want to see one with a woman
let's get a real let's get a real take
here
uh and get a full assessment I'm a cat
this is what he looks like this is way
back though this is from his uh YouTube
pranking days this is what he looks like
I don't know why he looks like kind of
normal which freaks me out more
what he looks like now
all right let's see
okay yes let's take a look this man
approaches you in Walmart
yeah yeah yeah
he's not super intimidating looking but
he does look [ __ ] crazy I'd be more
willing to talk to this one I think than
the other one you think so the other one
looks creepier and if that one that guy
approaches you with like really bizarre
words
I would like to be away from him more
than I would like to be aware okay
interesting interesting
yeah I'm not
sure
well [ __ ] in my sink and give me a wink
look at this hairy little [ __ ] huh you
know look at this hairy little [ __ ]
look at this hair y little [ __ ]
whereas Kenneth would say hlp remember
this
so a lot of people were asking for a
dolphin dive high five tutorial
feels like one of the crooks from Home
Alone
as the slippery Bandits Marv I think
right here so at least he's not that
intimidating looking you know
if he was like six four all I don't know
there you go I mean I don't know what to
tell you guys I just love how he's got
his own inside thing going on I'll be
honest I'm just waiting for the dobrik
see
[Music]
we don't have to wait but here on the
air for that what we're gonna try it on
air oh you want to try it on yeah that's
the whole point gotcha I'm not trying to
just eat pizza
all right well here you want you had a
challenge for me Amy you wanted me to
react to this old school prank video
that you think yes I'm gonna hate dude I
don't know I hope he's this this is the
prolapse to me
this is your problem I know it's a huge
claim but my God this was uploaded one
month ago so it's it's relevant this is
top-notch idiots
three million it's 3.2 million Subs 2.4
million views after a month the title is
10-year coma prank gone wrong must watch
Yo those titles are still popping these
guys keep all the same elements and I
love them for it I they did like a
recently like uh do you want to get
naked prank with Naked Juice I was like
what year is it I think it's getting
views because oh there's a lot of views
yeah yeah big time how trying to get
chopped up or what what they're doing
like pranks in the hood yes
well I gotta I got yeah and that was
actually the one that blew my mind last
night I don't know if we'll have time to
get to it today because you want him to
watch the other one yeah please yes okay
uh you want me to watch this one
specifically yes okay all right so here
it is this is the tenure in a coma prank
gone sexual gone wild must watch
foreign
trauma this is already giving me Josh
Taylor Lynn Sky skydiving you remember
that
offer you to process
you know what's awesome though this
reminds me of early milk like if these
guys stick it through they can have a
media Empire host a huge podcast for all
the men of the world hell yeah make an
alcoholic beverage
the lower the IQ the better for men's
content I swear to God that's my theory
and it's living up to it
I'm done I
always bro this for sure is the same
audience that watched milk it is
to hit another Millie this year we
accomplished it sooner than I expected
you can skip a little bit in the
beginning if you want the premises
they're gonna get their boys super drunk
okay yeah wait wait go back a little bit
yeah right there okay so he's drunk he's
like 13 shots
yeah
get your dirty ass
I'm gonna skip the drink we keep on
stacking it what's happening
but yeah so they drug they drugged him
as well which is insane awesome
practice but this is obviously fake I
mean yeah it goes without being said
yeah so the original of this one is Josh
Baylor Lynn he pretended that his
friends somehow
got him passed out
carried his body onto an airplane right
the skydiving and then jumped out with
him that's a classic bro that was good
maybe we should pull that up I bet a lot
of people haven't seen that
what did you give him some strong sleep
cool are they for horses dude
that's not even funny like that's not
even like cool to pretend like you did
yeah no none of us that's like they
roofied their friend in this video
really that's a felony like you
shouldn't even like act like that's
something that you did because people
are going to think that that's what you
do and so they're probably gonna kill
someone to be honest Jesus they're like
how many [ __ ] NyQuil pills do I need
so that he doesn't wake up on an
airplane
how'd you get him there what is this saw
he just wakes up there
wait also I just realized his shoes are
there so have those shoes been there for
10 years wait where's his shoes on the
left
oh oh they're not there right there okay
when they zoom out a little bit yeah by
the way
um I'm seeing if they wrote that it's
just a sketch or something in the in the
description because like
otherwise
it's just them committing a felony it's
a prank bro
I can't believe this man you're right AB
this is like
this is it this is the golden day of
pranks yeah back
this is crazy bro
foreign
how are you doing
well you know that you're in the
hospital and you've been in a coma for
the last 10 years
I know that that's a big
surprise to you we suffered some brain
trauma that's going to be a lot for you
to process
you a friend of yours
that wants to see you is that okay with
you is it okay if we bring him in to see
you okay here he comes
[Music]
should be right back
by the way it's like obviously not in a
hospital
it just looks like an office building
like look at this [ __ ] yeah which
hospital have you seen with these kind
of [ __ ] blinds hanging down there
but okay you gotta see how they age are
the people watching this thinking it's
real yeah no way but let it play this is
the entrance of all entrances this is
what goes this video they gotta see the
makeup they do for their friend to make
them look 10 years older okay hold on
somebody in the chat just said maybe
it's not a sketch y'all please try and
[ __ ] start with me you know when I
was showing some of my friends back home
they thought some of them thought it was
real like that was wrong with you guys
you guys just haven't been on YouTube
long enough maybe I don't know yeah
I think we're getting them some
subscribers I see people saying it's
messed up but it's funny they deserve it
well if you guys want a sub it's
top-notch idiots which is also
um interestingly the uh what they call
their subs as well thank you Zach where
you at
[Music]
yes what the [ __ ] so he aged himself
and and he got fat like what happened
they put a they put a pillow in his
stomach and then gave him a double chin
like a big ass double chin
yeah
what
top though bro dude
he doesn't look old he looks like he's
wearing a shitty prosthetic
it's up though bro I would be tripping
off I said
what the hell I I bought his glasses I
was I was I love this video so much I
was about to recreate it but I didn't
have enough time back in Michigan let me
see those are the same ones yeah where'd
you get them I got them from Amazon how
much
six bucks those aren't the same ones
stop it it's opto bro
you remember me
do you remember me
what's the last thing you remember bro
three million Subs three million Subs
yeah bro that night you fell down you
were really drunk we got all lit you
fell down you hit your head really bad
bro you lost consciousness
so we brought you to the hospital that's
great time has not been well to your
friend
apparently he had his skin grafted yeah
he gained a lot of weight
oh brother had some really bad plastic
surgery
yeah just dude I can make a banger H3
video I know I know that's what I was
thinking the whole time that's what I
really wanted to show it to you I was
like this is the sketch potential is
crazy it's amazing
oh [ __ ] makes me kind of want to do it
because I haven't seen content like this
in YouTube I'm not doing it I'll give
you these glasses what I don't have the
time for all that that would be dude
people trip I just uploaded like a super
classic activity we would get over that
2.89 Mark you think so yeah
dude how am I gonna have the time to do
that dude it is like oh Luna's here
Pizza time it's like the perfect H3
video because it's the culmination of
all those guys like they haven't changed
up at all wow we got doe bricks Lena
guess what we're watching uh Lina okay
we're watching
you already know okay first of all not a
fancy box
so hold on Gleaner you want to come I'll
ask you some questions so we can finally
get to the bottom of this
so I was promised a fancy box with a
coin in it
who told you that he did
oh I see you got a bunch of different
slices
you couldn't get a full pie you could
but um they said only of one one flavor
depending on how busy it is they'll let
you get but um because it wasn't too
busy they said I could get one full pie
so you guys um
you guys got slices back there to try
yeah there's some back there for
everyone okay so was it busy no it
wasn't empty not empty there was there
was people sitting outside I didn't have
to wait I walked in and I ordered um
was there people there enjoying their
Pizza
and how much was it
12 slices and it was
the slices for 80 bucks each one was
like 650 I think first you guys hear
that everybody's gone by the way there's
no not one person in their seat
but like they're not regular slices you
can see they're pretty thick
very breading yeah
a lot of bread are they doughy
very very dully very doughy so do you
want to try one of these with me I did I
had one on the way here what flavor
cheese I decided I did oh [ __ ] and you
liked it so do you know what flavor this
is here then you have veggie in your
hand
glue
is the dough gooey or is that
I don't know yeah it looks like the
pesto
I do it's really salty
mm-hmm
my cheese was okay
and then what's this one here that one
is spicy vodka I don't know what that
means like vodka sauce probably mm-hmm
oh that's right vodka sauce
is it it's so good I already had one
yeah on my way here it's did you hear
how much it was how much was it how many
slices 84
um 12 slices
Jesus
[Music]
Pizza like it's not hard for me to be
like ah it's all right
I don't mind the microwave stuff and
everything yeah
this is like DiGiorno not that bad okay
this is not that good this is extremely
mid which flavor are you eating just
cheese
it's way too doughy
like too thick sure of like a home baked
pizza
is horrible I'll eat it like look at
this like that's good for a heavy slice
it holds up but the dough is like an
inch thick
your overall rating I mean listen it's a
style right the thick though
[Music]
I don't know what style it is it's it's
like a Chicago deep dish Vibe
um no but we had it's supposed to be
that authentic Chicago right and I'm not
saying that I'm not saying it's that
oh I already got oh what is that yeah I
want to try the cheese yeah and for what
apparently the prices for this pizza
that's a horrible value okay let's try
the cheese this is the one I really want
to try here
lots of Parmesan I liked it
or maybe I was just really hungry I was
running errands and you know it was
lunch time yeah yeah maybe I was just
really hungry
those super doughy ones are not really
my cup of tea
does anybody like the really doughy
I do like I yeah I don't mind that
yeah I wonder if it was warm if it'd be
better yeah obviously mine's lukewarm
traffic was pretty bad it was 51 minutes
to get back here somebody says land
DiGiorno is Bomb listen you can feel
that way that's fine I don't think it's
that bomb but also DiGiorno's doesn't
cost 80 for 12 slices that's what I'm
saying that's [ __ ] you know what I
mean I'll eat DiGiorno I'm not I'm not
trying to [ __ ] on it too much but what
was the atmosphere like inside
casual we did it was it nice it was
pretty small
um there was like a tiny disco ball
hanging from the ceiling
did you ever see it go off no so I've
already done the coin thing
at least that with each Pizza you get a
coin
that you can put and have a mini disco I
don't know didn't Sam say that they were
like over doing it yeah yeah
it just seemed like a regular pizza
place honestly there wasn't anything
like different or unusual going on
I was a customer service
okay yeah no complaints
nothing like over the top either like
not
any pizza shop I felt like people are
saying it looks good
honestly it does look good there's a
nice like crust on the crust the crust
is good let me try this yeah
regarding the price I don't think it's
bad for like per slice because they're
so thick yeah it tastes like School
pizza
I'd give this like a nine oh whoa wow
what flavor did you try I had the um
with flavor pepperoni with the honey is
there honey on this
I didn't taste any honey on it yeah it
didn't say anything it just had
pepperoni pizza well there's something
sweet on there this [ __ ] was a it was
good
hmm
so I guess if you're into the thick one
you might like it I give it away I kind
of really [ __ ] with it oh my God it's
good I'm full after one slice too so I
guess the price point yeah same cam yeah
me too trades off for that
[ __ ]
oh I got the pepperoni honey
oh my God this thing is
covered
they were all six First Slice because
this one looks pretty stacked there it
was like six something each one the
scents may have varied for different
types of pizzas shreddy really wants
this I'm pretty sure lots of snacks
should I try to get them give them
something and I'll deal with it at home
okay thank you
oh it's ready
a bunch of pepperoni
what's the final verdict
out of ten I mean for me it's not
terrible it's not a total disaster I
would say I would agree with that
but it's not amazing
[Music]
honestly
if I was out drinking and I stopped here
I wouldn't be mad about it
hello
maybe it's maybe I don't know
six six and a half
coach bear I would go a little lower I'd
probably say like a five five and a half
edible
decent nothing
too memorable though
definitely have better Pizza
I mean I do like the inventive flavors
like spicy
um
I haven't tried that I just tried the
standard cheese so maybe they're better
with their this veg you want is like
gooey it's like I feel like I'm eating
egg white
what's a goated pizza for you Dan
goated Pizza yeah
[ __ ]
you got up
because
the difference between like a New York
slice and like a Chicago deep dish right
okay fair show is so vast
it's almost like apples and oranges to
me you ever have baronis in in the
valley what's that baronis you have a
Baroni's is good that's see that's a
goated piece of fruit yeah that place
was great
so we got to keep it real right we keep
it real with our product reviews
happy Dad got a good rating
oh yeah I'm not letting my Prime got a
good rating my thoughts on dobric affect
this I wanted to hate it
But ultimately is this special enough to
Warrant it existing at all
okay if I want to go that far but I
would but again
I mean
Lena said that she didn't think it was
too bad I think I mean 12 slices granted
they're big slices but still eighty
dollars that's crazy
think about how much pizza 80 gets you
at like Domino's pizza or something
three or four extra large right you can
feed them you can uh more like some
borrow like buy the slice because that
would be about the same
right like three seconds three bucks and
that pizza is better I'm just gonna say
that pizza is better Pizza is actually
tomorrow pizzas yeah it's better than
this it probably yeah
it's part of it is that you don't have
the EXP you're not buying a 12 slice of
pizza you're buying like a three or four
dollars wait so how much does a slice
that sparrows or whatever it's a borrows
honestly I haven't been there so long it
was still around go to malls anymore
yeah yeah like rarely me and Lena had a
Michigan a few times
God I could crush a pizza right now
we gotta go out
Ethan I work yeah maybe that hospital
have you looked into feeding Shredder
Hills wet food called A.D
I'll try that they say they feed that
when dogs won't eat anything else you
see slices between like four and five
dollars there oh so it's not that I've
never been cheaper yeah small people
borrow menu prices slice of cheese 329.
hey Foster I'm going to save this
comment and try that thank you for the
whole 10 inch pizza is eight bucks
yeah versus one place is eight bucks
10 inches pretty small group or what is
it it was 80 bucks for two
two pizzas yeah something eighty dollars
of dominoes literally gets you like 12
pizzas I think that's true because they
they if you buy in bulk it's like six
seven bucks a pie no no no no no no no
no no yeah dude [ __ ] a few nights ago
dominoes we ordered online it was fifty
dollars for like two [ __ ] you didn't
pick the right coupons yeah you if you
didn't coupon you get [ __ ] bro where
was your honey dude where was honey dude
I [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up the more I eat
it the less I like it it's too doughy
like it's just too doughy bro what's in
the name it is dobrics and that's it
look at this thing because I I didn't
mind that about it at all it's just
you're eating very so much bread yeah
that's true
would you order this pizza
Zach you loved it would you order this
to your house yeah oh and I know I know
Chantal would dig it too because she
likes the the thick crust do it then
not for eighty dollars [ __ ] that daring
him I'd do it then send us send us a
selfie with your dobre I'll go with my
dad and he'll pay that's that's what
I'll do yes yes that's a that's a have
the parents pay for it kind of thing
exactly
what you mean because my dad and I we go
on these food excursions so it's like
one of those like okay you pay for it
yeah
all right it's not bad
I'm in
if you like doughy Pizza you'll like it
you'll really like it
you're it just popped in my head what it
reminds me of
because it's not quite Chicago style
because that's like the very specific
it's like almost like a [ __ ]
casserole kind of pizza or whatever
you guys remember I don't know if they
do it anymore but at Pizza Hut they used
to have pan pizzas yes where it was like
real thick would they call it it was
called pan pizza I like cooked it in
like a metal pan that's what this is I
think that is exactly how this is this
is like a a combo of that but almost
like a Detroit style pizza like if you
know it all right how many how many
areas get their own pizza name somebody
said Numero Uno style yes Numero Uno did
they go out of business I love I don't
know but yeah as [ __ ] that was like
their things they had that thick eye it
was good though yeah they got it was
better than this they got a good chicken
parm sub there yeah yeah anyways wait
you guys talking about Chicago
no I'm done with giving Pitt regions
pizzas no I'm just saying there's a
there's like a well-known Chicago yes I
believe that's genos
this is like Minnesota style pizza to be
honest you know it reminds me of um
upper Wisconsin stuff yeah have you guys
ever had Connecticut Pizza yes I have
Cam so you guys are you guys are
throwing these names out but there
probably is pizza for that reason this
is salt like this is giving me Salt Lake
City Pizza Vibes yeah for sure I'm
getting a Reno Nevada Pizza Vibes here I
can't I don't I can't keep all those
pizza types in my head
well there's there's core two or three
it's uh you know uh New York New York
and Chicago and I standard there's an
American Standard transatlantic standard
New York Pizza is like just pizza
oh the New Yorkers in the chat are about
to [ __ ] pop the [ __ ] off on you dude
I'm just saying that's like become the
norm
that's like Standard Pizza
all right
I think they would disagree
so what the [ __ ] whatever
I don't eat pizza anymore
look how many slices I didn't eat though
good for you would you like me to take
it away
yeah take it away from me okay
remove the Temptation please
okay I mean overall I guess I'll say I'm
impressed just because it's not terrible
yeah
dude you're Menace
I ruined I'm the host I'm trying to
[ __ ] do a show here that's a party
Foul dude I'm doing a show party Foul
for the people
it's for the people Dan where you at
[Music]
New Yorker here New York pizza's mid bro
I don't want to say it but I agree with
you
the pizza in New York's not that good
sorry so what's goated pizza for you
Ethan listen it's just I don't believe
in Styles it just
would you rather me eat it all Dan no
guess that Bel Air style pizza you
massacred my boy
that was once pepperoni it's my job bro
I'm not talking about like specific
Styles like is there a place that's a
go-to for you like other than Domino's
you know there's just one place actually
have you guys tried Lucifer uh-uh it's
really good Lucifer Lucifer in L.A
there's one on Melrose right there's one
in
uh Sherman Oaks I think too or Encino
something or Studio City Sam and I get
it all the time that's good [ __ ]
really really good
yeah it's really good
if you're in Boston try my favorite
Portland style pizza which is Otto
Portland bro you did not just hit me
with pork pizza
why would I get Portland Pizza it's just
called them or Otto Portland I don't
know if it's so where do we need to go
to get Portland Pizza you gotta go to
Boston Boston actually got it
specifically you got to go to Harvard
Square in Cambridge
you're gonna dress like cam to get in
there yeah anybody's welcome
tell them camps aren't you they won't
know who I am use code cam for Portland
Pizza all right listen guys it's 4 30.
[Music]
we had a great show here today yes sir
you're not finishing the video what
video of this one okay I'll finish it I
forgot it's such a [ __ ] long tangent
it's a very long time
3 million subscribers has been it's been
a minute how you feeling good
I don't know we we had no hope we didn't
know when you were gonna wake up bro
because honestly it's just shocking
driving I love how he's just like bro
bro so serious bro you didn't know when
you would wake up bro
I heard your voice in such a long time
bro Casper called he's uh you know he's
gonna be he's on his way you're with
Jessica right yeah yeah uh you got her
pregnant brother
I've been you know I've been taking care
of your kid I've been helping them
financially
wants to meet you okay
[Music]
he's such a good actor he's really
selling it by sitting there completely
worse
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like an office sketch yeah totally
with the camera outside
it's funny because this is genuinely
I don't know what am I supposed to be
feeling right now I guess it's funny I
suppose they're getting them so good
yeah I don't know he's so confused
that's the thing it's just it's a mind
[ __ ] this is the Matrix
oh yeah
I just want to check out a few things
hello I'm Dr Michaels what is your name
my name's Chris nice to meet you Chris
I'm just going to check a few things on
your dad okay yeah
doctor sucks yeah doctor sucks [ __ ] you
doctor taking it too seriously
people saying they feel good don't feel
bad you go back a little bit he's in on
it I hope that's clear yes he's not a
real prank guys very fake guys listen to
me this is fake
we obviously missed the first half of my
career right I'm glad you're here but
you missed a few things
this is Casper Casper they didn't age
him at all yeah
for a second set of makeup is this cash
they didn't age that's awful bro yeah
he walks in you see he's completely the
same
huh
let me tell you something bro like his
face
he looks like a Marvel villain or some
[ __ ] I don't know she's not right
let me tell you something bro
you know you're gonna go out of pressure
in the world then it's not like how you
know you left left it back then
10 years yeah a lot has changed within
the past tense the kid thought he was
supposed to talk like that over the past
10 years kids trying to add work it was
wrong that's just dumb I know oh also
there are uh pale elf women uh Avatar
Avatar
Avatar 3 changed everything maybe we'll
like that one that'll be the best bear
Ethan L it's actually real I know you're
kidding you know this one's real Ethan
thank you so someone who actually
y'all remember the Joey salads Fiasco
they actually took 10 years to shoot
this video they waited yeah high level
filmmaking yeah they're committed to the
bit it was like boy
there's nothing wrong with it
the kid got super excited
they even hit him with his sister
oh yeah no this is all
it's the culmination of years of
pranking combined
do you know that one day
bro that part really got me that part
with the kid really bro but she came in
I was like okay hold on a second
there's no well if this is nobody saw
him with that makeup on and was like oh
yeah if this is real
then you're also accepting that they
roofied him right he dragged his
lifeless body right and and got him into
a hospital into a hospital gown strapped
up to an IV in this room and he'd never
stirred
you got her pregnant brother
bro bro you're with Jessica right send
me the Josh Taylor limb one real fast
because I want you all to see where the
origin story of this and then I'm and
then I really got to go
his name I got it I got it hey okay I
got it Josh Taylor Lin
I always wondered how this guy wasn't
deported because I think he's like a
Chinese uh student visa and he's always
getting trouble with the police and [ __ ]
and doing like dumb horrible illegal
[ __ ] I was like how has he not been
deported I feel the same with Vitaly
like you know what I mean like I'm
pro-immigration I want to open the
borders but we got to
deported I draw the line
undocumented workers can stay I want to
deport pranksters the top comment on
this Josh Taylor Lynn is on my birthday
my friends threw me in a volcano must
have been wearing earplugs right
drop down
people think this shit's real
hey guys so I didn't really want to put
this video up because I just got pranked
big time on my birthday
but my embarrassment will be your
enjoyment so here it is all right so
today is Josh's birthday we just go back
to the club oh my God this is crazy I'm
getting such flashbacks no this guy was
was his own goon with his own prank
Channel I didn't remember his name these
people have like faded into Oblivion
I don't know who the [ __ ] this is but
whatever
crazy first birthday so we're gonna
throw him out of an airplane tomorrow
morning
[Laughter]
all right so we're on our way to
skydiving wait wait they don't even
explain it no next day it's morning he's
passed out in the back at least
as you can see Josh is still out
he's gonna be fun
here he is sleeping
in a bright field
[Music]
you ever been next to an airplane
loud
[Music]
become [ __ ] loud as you can't even
hear them
look at this
[Music]
and then it's just a video of them
skydiving here on my music because yeah
you got that Jack man it's just him
skydiving
and then he lands so that I don't need
to watch him skydive
okay you can bring it back
oh my God
please tell me he says like And
subscribe
yeah man oh my God nice meeting you
you're hugging
he was unconscious all halfway he said
don't you have to go through safety
training first
yeah if you're straddled to someone I
don't think so right no you definitely
still need to oh yeah
it's a tutorial hold on do you think
it's an Insurance liability to throw a
sleeping person out of a plane
maybe no
surprise surprise he's still posting on
Facebook is he getting views on Facebook
five likes oh that oh that hurts
bro that actually hurts
is that crazy enough for you yeah it
might surprise you I'm so tired he's
gonna pass that again
I'm surprised you didn't know it this
guy was one of the biggest [ __ ]
pranksters on YouTube in a minute and he
was doing here's his popular ones you
know 52 million this was super hot
giving a homeless man a hundred dollars
and then following them to see how they
spend it they're all fake by the way
he goes I want to see if he's going to
buy drugs or alcohol with the money I
gave him oh and then he ends up this is
awesome one then he ends up going and
buying food and sharing it with other
homeless people supposed to be inspired
you ever wonder how they spent it today
I might give a homeless guy a hundred
dollars hey I'm gonna follow him and see
how he spend it bro do you understand
how problematic that is already
oh
here he is running hey hey how you doing
good how are you I'm all right I'm Josh
I promise nice to meet you yeah I just
tried to make him up to get me something
to eat I just want to like give it back
to people I'm not gonna be there
honestly it's super entertaining but
it's crazy and then the other ones that
was really one of the worst
most damaging one I'd say predecessors
to Andrew Tate
is the gold digger pranks
which were super popular
here this is two minutes
how to prank a gold digger like a boss
23 million no
those top-notch guys are still doing
gold digger pranks
really yeah they put a spin on it though
the girls still like them even after
they find out that it's fake oh because
they're max they're all messed up it's
pretty cute
to hang out sometime no I don't think so
I'm here I'm just new here so I just
want to see you you know okay chill hang
out something I have a boyfriend you do
yeah I mean we can just be friends you
know it doesn't have to go it's kind of
serious I don't think it's a good idea
nothing give my number out to people I
don't know sorry sure yeah all right
well bye
just wait
10 minutes later
yo we got a million dollar deal going on
on Thursday we can't screw this up trust
me yeah I know it's a simple
about 48 million we're looking at
Buy sell Buy sell yeah totally okay let
me call you back
bye hi how's it going hi
are you um are you sitting here alone
yeah I am mind if I join you yeah you
don't have to have a boyfriend or
anything by any chance do you yeah what
do you got going on later on tonight
women huh
they're the worst damn yeah these
actually these comments are like uh
preserved if I developed for every girl
that found me unattractive they would
find me attractive that's kind of funny
actually
foreign
this is what pranks need to be nowadays
I hate the pranks where people get hurt
it's so sad but these pranks are devious
and hilarious
best prank ever a lot of a lot of them
are super misogynistic let's see
uh whatever [ __ ] it I gotta go you guys
you gotta take care of my dog he needs
medicine and [ __ ]
all right
thank you everybody
tomorrow morning we're back
that's right
a lot to talk about
that'll be good then looking forward to
it our break uh was an insane time in
American politics so uh also Hassan got
a mullet so I got a mullet we need to
confront him about that I'm not a mullet
fan you know something not really about
it either it's just
you should shave it and bleach it that's
what I think
all right I really gotta go thank you
guys for watching we'll see you tomorrow
morning love you all
peace
[Music]